What you're about to hear is part four
of a multipart series on the first world
war,
if you like,
your stories to have some sort of
cohesive linear narrative flow.
Although I'm not promising that I
probably couldn't deliver on that,
but if that's what you like,
we're probably better off suggesting you
go check out episode number one and work
your way to hear.
If you don't care about that kind of
stuff at all,
or you just don't trust me to deliver a
cohesive linear narrative flow and I
wouldn't blame you.
Well then by all means,
start here at part four and check out
this series that we're calling blueprint
for Armageddon.
Be Bus seven,
19,
41,
a date which will live in infamy.
It's history.
Perfect.
The events
that dude figures from this time and
place,
I take pride in the words,
been the Alina,
tear down,
complete collapse.
Welcome this kind of examination because
people have got to know whether or not
the president said,
well,
I'm not a crop.
If we dig deep in our history and our
doctrine,
I don't remember if we are not descended
from fearful of man,
it's hardcore history.
How do you market war,
how do you sell combat to the people who
are actually going to have to engage in
it?
It's not a hypothetical question,
by the way.
Any military that requires volunteers to
decide they want to join the service has
to think about how you actually sell the
idea to the people who you know have to
take part in it.
An idea that carries with it the
potential for some very nasty outcomes
in the very worst of circumstances,
doesn't it?
So difficult job perhaps to market
combat.
It's easier to do in peace time though,
right?
If you have to sell Suntan oil to people
in Alaska,
you might be able to pull that off in
the summer in December.
It's a really tough sell before the
first world war breaks out.
If you're trying to market recruitment
into the British army,
you can sell the same sort of talking
points,
the same soda angles that have worked
for governments and monarchies and
tribes.
Going back to the beginning of
civilization,
the military has long had certain
selling points.
I think we're all familiar with them.
You could add regular pay thrown in to
that as well.
The heroism,
the adventure,
the status.
I mean,
you know,
there's a lot of things.
Some people just like to fight.
I mean,
you never know.
The problem is is that that's a pre
1914,
you know,
talking point when it comes to what
happens when the first world war breaks
out and how that just totally messes
with your marketing strategy.
Unless you're marketing hell as a travel
destination,
you can't,
no matter how much precedence or ship
you have,
and the British had plenty in the first
world war,
just like everyone else,
you can't mask those kinds of casualty
number.
Now you can mask the reality,
the sort of stuff that some of these
newspaper reporters who were censored
during the war,
after the war,
you know,
they would write books,
telling you the real story,
what really happened because you
couldn't have imagined it and it was all
censored by the press.
Even with the censorship,
you can't hide the death and destruction
and dismemberment and you see the people
returning to your hometown with the
horrible wounds and you hear some of the
rumors and stories,
you know it's not going to be fun.
All of a sudden the marketers in Great
Britain's recruitment operation have to
play hard ball no more just throwing out
carrots they're going to use some sticks
to.
In the US.
We have a 21st century volunteer army
ourselves and the US uses just carrots
to encourage people to join up.
We'll pay you more.
We'll pay you for college.
You'll make something of your life.
I mean,
there's all these different things that
they used to motivate people,
but there's not very many sticks in the
US system.
Once the first couple of weeks of the
first world war happened and everybody
together finds out how enormous this is
going to be an in an absolutely stunning
group.
Wake up call where the light goes on
over everyone's head and they're going,
oh my gosh,
we don't have enough resources and oh my
gosh,
we don't have enough money for a war
like this,
and Oh my gosh,
we don't have enough people,
and even some of these larger states
where you think to yourself,
all you know,
people shouldn't be a problem.
Look at how many people are coming up.
Every generation.
Remember manpower in the old,
you know,
air quotes means manpower across the
board.
Not just the people fighting on the
front line,
but the people that can still be minors
to extract the material you need to
carry on the war or people working in
arms manufacturing plants so that they
can build the bombs you need to fight
the war.
In other words,
if you take too much to throw on the
fighting line,
you won't have enough people back home
making the stuff that the people on the
fighting line need to win.
Man,
power becomes a very big deal.
All these other countries in the war,
Germany,
France,
Russia,
no problem.
They've spent decades working out a
conscription operation where they draft
people,
you know,
you come of age,
you do a couple of years in the service
and then you become parts of the
reserves and then you become parts of
the other reserve and the heavier and
older reserve and you know,
after a while they've got a whole
revolving self perpetuating system in
place.
Whereas every generation comes up,
they're cranking out new soldiers except
for Great Britain there,
the last volunteer service in involved
in this conflict.
When it breaks out,
it puts unique pressures on them.
The first thing they do is simply ask
people to join up.
And remember in 1914 you didn't quite
know what you were in for.
You could still sell the old selling
points.
The uniforms are wonderful and the
women,
you'll look dashing and it just be,
you know,
I mean war adventure killed the Bosch,
all the good methods that king needs.
You,
king and country,
all the things that have always worked
and still work by the way.
And a lot of cases,
especially in peace time.
Um,
worked in more folks in Britain.
And Scotland and Canada and Australia
and all these places signed up than they
even could handle.
They were looking for a couple of
hundred thousand,
got a lot more than that,
but that's before the casualties start
happening.
A lot of patriotic Britain signup,
but you don't know how many patriotic
Britain's journey you're going to need
and not just in one big lump,
but every month to replace the troops.
You lose.
In late 1915,
the British just lose at Gullapalli and
they walk away after a couple of months
with 250,000
casualties.
You don't just replace those by playing
nice and easy and saying,
come and fight for king and country.
You're using more hardball methods,
and one of the ones that I've always
thought was just indicative of something
that if you imagined it in modern times,
it boggles the mind using a strategy
like this today,
but it's absolute genius.
It shows exactly the most vulnerable
point in a young man's psyche.
I mean the place where if you're a
marketer,
you're looking for,
for you know,
what motivates people,
how you can touch these,
these elements of influence in the order
of the feather.
The white feather movement is absolutely
brilliant in that regard.
I mean,
it's almost devious.
You try to imagine our government doing
something like this today with modern
21st century technology.
It's interesting to think about,
but basically,
you know when August,
early September,
19,
14 rolls around,
there's an admiral in the British
admiralty who's,
who's working like everyone else to
think about,
well,
how can we encourage more people to sign
up for this horrible war and comes up
with,
you know,
and an attack on a motivation,
a marketing strategy.
He's going to enlist patriotic young
British women to walk the streets of all
these towns in Britain,
their hometowns.
You know,
where there are people they know and if
they see men not in uniform,
who looked like they could be or should
be,
they are going to go up,
surround this person and start saying
the most horrible thing.
You are a coward and all these terrible
things to them.
In know pretty women in public dressing
you down if you're 18 years old,
that's a pretty good marketing chink in
arm or to exploit,
not just that you're probably in.
Usually we're on the streets of your
hometown where the pastors by no you or
your family.
This is a profoundly embarrassing
moment,
you know,
for,
for everyone around you,
everyone connected with you.
God forbid if you have a girlfriend,
she's gonna think this looks pretty bad
for her too.
I mean,
the effect was,
was huge.
And then before this little group of
women,
um,
we're done with you.
They would put a white feather
signifying cowardice on your lapel or
somewhere very visible,
you know,
on you.
This was not an unusual occurrence.
There are accounts for people that say
they were afraid to go outside the house
sometimes because these patriotic and
zealous women who were really just
trying to help.
That's the funny part.
This is the society motivating,
patriotism,
all these things,
right?
It's,
it's all the right virtues.
But I've got an account from a 16 year
old boy who had to go through this and
then he signed up for the service
because he was so deathly embarrassed
and afraid and an inch and ashamed and
the service person laughed him out of
the room,
but then said he looked so downtrodden,
he exaggerated this height,
exaggerated,
does age,
exaggerated his weight,
and he was in at 16 under 110 pounds on
the western front.
It's absolutely deviously clever.
Once again,
I try to imagine us using it today.
You know,
these ideas could backfire though.
These creative marketing recruitment
ideas,
for example,
the government felt the need to put out
symbols that people could wear who had
already done their service overseas and
had been wounded and honorably
discharged or who worked for some really
important armaments or war related
industry and couldn't be spared because
apparently enough of those people were
being mistakenly given the order of the
white feather treatment to make that an
important thing for the government to
do.
There were other creative marketing
plans,
not sticks but carrots and one of them,
another brilliant one.
When you think about it on the surface,
involve the British government
explaining to recruits that if you sign
up with your pals,
your buddies,
you could all serve together as well.
People joined up from the same street or
the same pub or the same community or
the same fraternity or the same
profession and they all serve together
and they had wonderful names.
These are like military unit names that
they're still known by.
I mean there were the Liverpool pals or
the grimsby chums and these friends all
went to the service.
She figured if you've got to serve,
you might as well do it with your
friends,
but then you get to watch your friends
die.
It's the part we didn't really consider
when we signed up and it sounded kind of
fun.
Not just that when these units would get
decimated in some of these terrible
encounters.
For example,
you can be walking down a road with your
pals in the open and all of a sudden get
caught by our Taylor refire,
suffer 80 percent casualties and then
instead of the losses and the suffering
and the grief being spread out,
sort of diluted across the width and
breadth of the entire British isles or
British empire for that matter,
some local community or some fraternity
or some profession just gets pounded and
there are villages and towns in Britain
now that had these terrible days just
happened to the whole community and
pretty much everybody suffers a major
loss one way or the other,
and if the downside of that clever
marketing plan by 1916,
there's nothing clever enough to get
enough people in uniform.
The losses are so high that the British
finally do what the British really don't
do and they started conscripting their
people.
It's hard to blame the British for
starting the same sort of draft that the
continental great powers use.
All you have to do.
As we said,
the casualties were so high.
Look at the.
By the end of Nineteen 15,
the British have suffered half a million
casualties,
200,000
of those are dead by the way,
for a traditionally naval power who has
traditionally are rather small army by
continental standards.
Those are huge numbers.
Now you want to see what continental
standards look like.
Look at the British ally,
the French who had a huge army in the
meat grinder since the first minute of
this whole affair,
and by the end of Nineteen 15 there
casualties are over 2 million.
More than 700,000
of those are dead and all these great
powers are looking at their principal
enemies and trying to figure out how
close they are to the throwing in the
towel moment.
The Germans are looking at the French
and all the casualties they have
suffered,
and then you're looking in their
thinking.
They must be close to the end of their
rope.
The Germans have suffered more
casualties by the end of 1915,
then the French,
but they're fighting on more fronts,
right?
They're fighting the French and the
British in the west,
the gigantic Russian forces in the east
and they're involved in the Balkans a
lot.
In 1915 there,
casualties by the end of 1915 or over
two and a half million,
about 750,000
of those are dead hard to know.
The Germans list 250,000
missing in this war.
People got blown to bits.
They got covered up by a giant mountains
of earth that Shell's had blown up in
the air,
falling back on the ground.
A lot of missing people probably between
750 and 800,000
dead for the Germans at this point in
the war.
The Russians have suffered titanic
losses from minute one.
They lost a huge battle in 1915 called
um,
Gorley's tarnoff.
We're to least a ton off.
And that battle all by itself,
they lost 150,000
dead,
almost 700,000
wounded and basically a million
prisoners.
Those titanic losses,
maybe it's easier to understand their
monthly burn rate by October 1915.
The Russians are losing 235,000
men a month.
How sustainable is that?
You again,
you got to be looking at the Russians
thinking they're almost done and the
German high command kind of is now.
The Germans can't be too happy though
because their main ally,
the Austrian Hungarians are suffering
casualties that are every bit as
momentous as the Russians,
but they don't have the manpower to back
that up.
I mean in one four month period in 1915,
one four month period,
the Austrian suffer 750,000
casualties.
Boom.
That's in addition to the already
astounding casualties they took in the
few months right after the war started.
The Germans several times we'll have to
prop up the Austrians just to keep them
able to continue in the conflict and the
Austrians are a pain in the rear to
their German allies.
A lot of the time mean for Eric on
Falcon and the German commander in
charge in January of 1916.
He can't stand them.
They are always getting into some sort
of disaster that they then go to Falcon
Hein and ask for help getting out of and
to make matters worse,
it's usually a disaster that fund falcon
hind and warned them about in advance.
Don't do that.
It'll be a disaster.
And then they do it against his wishes
and then come and ask to be bailed out
multiple times.
They can always play their,
their trump card though,
against,
on Falcon Hine,
legitimately considering the huge
casualties they've suffered.
They can kind of go there and say,
well listen,
I mean,
you know,
if you don't help us,
uh,
we're not that far from dropping out of
the war.
I don't know.
I can't guarantee you will be here and
you know,
you have to help them.
Or it's a strategic disaster if the
Austro-hungarian dropout of the war.
Right,
but fun Falcon Hind doesn't want to pay
any attention to any of these other
friends.
He doesn't want to worry about the
Russians.
There are German generals and whatnot.
They keep saying,
we need to focus on the Russians.
That's how we win the war.
Falcon.
I didn't want to hear about that,
doesn't want to focus in the Balkans,
although in 1915 they destroy Serbia,
just get that out of the way,
fall behind,
doesn't want to hear about the Middle
East and the Turkey doesn't want to talk
about Australia and her problem doesn't
want to know what he's doing.
He wants to focus on this maybe war
winning or war,
losing Gordian Knot.
That is the puzzle that must be solved
if you are a general task with winning
this war.
It's the western front.
How do you deal with that and it and
it's an unprecedented problem.
You know there's a famous German saying
that may or may not have happened,
but it's infused this whole period where
one German general is supposed to have
commented about how amazingly the
British troops fought and he said
they're lions and the sub commander with
him is supposed to have said something
to the effect of Yes,
lucky for us,
they are led by donkeys.
Nineteen 15 is western front.
Battles are where the donkeys first get
labeled with that sort of reputation.
At the same time,
when you realize that they have no
metrics for what they're doing in 1915,
this has never been done before.
Nobody's ever had this kind of firepower
and nobody's ever put these kinds of
defenses up.
I mean,
we're playing with all sorts of new
military toys and they've never been
tested.
In a situation like this,
how much slack do you cut the generals
and give them what is sometimes called
by historians,
in this case,
a learning curve when you're playing
with people's lives,
how slowly are you allowed to figure
things out?
We didn't go into any of the 1915
battles.
Winston Churchill is just one of many
people who object to the whole idea of
calling those battles.
In the 19,
15 year or 1916 year or 1917 year
battles,
he says it's a disservice to what the
name means.
You said there were battles in 1914 at
the start of the war and there were
battles in 1918 at the end of the war,
but that stuff in the middle was a
siege.
He writes,
quote,
these sanguinary prodigious struggles
extending over many months are often
loosely described as battles,
judging by the number of men who took
their turn in the fighting at different
times by the immense quantities of guns
and shells employed and by the hideous
casualty totals.
They certainly rank taken as a whole
among the largest events in military
history,
but we must not be misled by
terminology.
You have to call them.
Battles was merely a method of
presenting a general view of an
otherwise confusing picture.
It might well pass unchallenged,
but an attempt has been made by military
commanders and buy a whole school of
writers to represent these prolonged
operations as events comparable to the
decisive battles of the past.
Only larger and more important to yield
to this specious argument is to be drawn
into a wholly wrong impression,
both of military science and of what
actually took place in the Great War and
quote,
these battles on the western front for a
full three years in the conflict look
pretty much like this as described by
historian older.
Her vague quote,
the fighting on the western front had
taken on a deadly regularity.
Attackers stormed enemy trenches in
waves only to be mowed down by hostile
machine gun firing artillery,
as they tried to cut the wire,
entanglements that protected the
earthworks and quote,
there's a repetitiveness to the fighting
on the western front.
It's a repetitiveness that actually is
associated with World War One and the
western front specifically.
It's part of the tragedy.
It adds to the pain because after all,
if you've seen this same event over and
over and over again,
doesn't it become a different kind of
tragic?
If you watch the first wave of those
young soldiers leave the safety of their
trench,
go over the top at the whistle of their
officer,
get down by machine gunfire before
they've even gone 10 feet.
That's tragic.
It's another level of tragedy.
When the next wave gets up right behind
them to follow in their footsteps.
Having already seen what happened to
them.
That's what we wanted to capture in our
discussions of the western front because
it became an issue early on how we were
going to deal with all these battles
that were roughly the same,
equally tragic and for the soldiers on
the ground.
Eerily similar when trying to figure out
what we wanted to highlight.
A shakespeare quote kept popping into my
head when I was working on this and it
was his line that all the world's a
stage and all the people merely players
and I thought to myself,
well,
that's what we have here.
We have one of the most extreme stages
in human history we've created with
these western front battles in 1915,
19,
16,
1917,
a hell like environment and then we
force millions of people to act in it,
but some of the most extreme situations
people have been put into ever in
history and watching how they endured is
sometimes soul crushing.
But at other times it's absolutely life
enhancing.
No,
sometimes you can benefit quite a bit
from the suffering of other people.
As we sat down when we started this
series and tried to figure out a
creative approach to dealing with all
these battles,
one thing becomes very clear and we did
some creative experiments and you
quickly find out that the battles in an
emotional sense reach a point of
diminishing returns very quickly.
You just become been benumbed by them
all the scale,
the intensity,
the sheer horrific repetitive pounding
eventually makes you stop feeling.
And so rather than go from I'm
indecisive and horrific battle to the
next indecisive and horrific battle,
we thought we would focus on a few,
what we would consider to be almost
signature battles,
if you will.
But they provide a very similar backdrop
for the poor individuals who have to
live in that environment and allow us to
sort of examined at a human level what's
going on here a little bit as best we
can.
And to explore some of the questions
that are very intriguing about the story
and not just about the human suffering
that about command decisions and some of
the technology and some other things.
Um,
hopefully interspersed with a little bit
of comment about what's going on in the
rest of the world.
Wild this is happening.
And part of what makes 1916 so difficult
is there's a lot of overlapping stuff.
So if you tell it in a he said,
she said then he said fashion.
It becomes very confusing very quickly.
The first thing to understand though is
that 1916 comes about obviously because
of plans made in late 1915.
We'd said to you earlier that this was a
real question for the generals about how
you solve this Gordian knot that is the
western front will.
In late 1915,
the allied command's got together at a
place called chantilly and France to
deal with this question.
They're plan was going to be to continue
to pound and pound harder,
but the new aspect was they were going
to make sure that everybody,
all the different allied powers pounded
the central powers,
Germany and friends at the same time,
they were going to coordinate their
efforts.
This was going to nullify what the
Germans had been doing.
So far.
The Germans have a great army,
but they can't be everywhere at once.
Luckily for them up until 1916,
they weren't attacked everywhere at
once,
so they would use something called
interior lines.
It's a little like taking the center
square in a game of tic TAC toe.
The Germans were able to use their
wonderful railway system to transfer
troops from less threatened sectors to
more hotspots and thereby frustrate
allied efforts.
So the allied plan for knocking down
German fortifications in 1916 is that
they're all going to attack it basically
the same time frustrating.
The Germans ability to move troops to
hotspots.
The Germans had a different plan
entirely.
You see the people at chantilly in 1950
new get together and decide to attack
the Germans from multiple locations at
the same time are still for the most
part in visioning the classic military
end to this war.
They see the chances increased by
attacking at multiple locations that
you're going to crack the Germans
somewhere and when you crack them,
you're going to send your forces through
the breach and you're going to send the
cavalry through and now the Germans are
going to break in.
They're going to be on the run and they
got to be routed towards Berlin and you
know that's how these things and in the
minds of people who have a very.
Especially in old fashioned view of war,
there are dissidence to this idea who
say,
even on the allied side,
you got it all wrong.
It's not going to happen that way.
The technology,
the specific circumstances,
the fact that there are no flying on the
western front,
you were dreaming and because you're
dreaming,
your plans aren't going to work.
Right?
On the German side,
the people who have this attitude that
that old fashioned viewpoint is just
that old fashioned happened to be in
positions of higher authority than the
dissident generals.
On the other side.
They've looked at the way the war is
going and figured out that the
casualties are the difference maker,
and then all these countries are
suffering because of the numbers of
people that are dying.
You need to increase the numbers.
People who were dying,
not only does it become hard to replace
them,
but it puts huge stresses and strains on
the societies that are losing these
people,
their families,
their governments.
Some of these societies are fragile
enough to simply fall apart like a house
of cards.
Others could have the entire population
turned on the government and say,
we know we've had enough.
That becomes the best path to end the
war in the minds of some of these
generals.
A guy like the leader in Germany,
Eric von Falcon Hine is looking at what
these 1915 battles taught him and they
taught him that modern warfare on the
western front turns into a meat grinder.
No matter what you do when he comes up
with the brilliant idea.
Again,
most historians still think,
uh,
some people say it's,
you know,
shooting an Arrow and painting a
bullseye around it afterwards.
But he comes up with the brilliant idea
that these meat grinders are happening
no matter what you designed the battle
to be like,
what if you designed the battle to be
like a meat grinder?
What if you create a meat grinder and
then entice the enemy to come into it if
that's what's so effective on the
battlefield?
What if you planned to grind meat
instead of having it be a byproduct of
other activities and plans?
And Falcon 19,
late 1915 determines that the French are
already,
you know,
near their breaking point in terms of
the casualties they've suffered and he
goes to the rest of the military
command.
He starts talking about what he'd like
to do in 1916 to try to win the war.
He wants to set a trap for the French
army.
The idea is to create one of these,
you know,
Modern Twentieth Century Attrition
Amplifiers,
one of these meat grinders and then Lou
or the French army into it.
For that,
you need bait
and the determination on where this
awful battles going to happen is
dependent on what site can be chosen
that would best play the role of Bait,
and I should point out that historians
from different countries disagree on
this.
Americans and British historians often
point out that this site chosen has no
real military value at all,
that it was solely chosen because it's
the perfect emotional bait to lure the
French army into the meat grinder.
German and French historians,
though often assert that this site did
have military importance and that that
you know,
did create a real military need to do
what the French ended up doing.
Nonetheless,
the German plan is to use all this
artillery first to pulverize the
defenses around this important site that
the French have an emotional and
political and everything else attachment
to below the French,
off of these hills that overlooked this
city.
This city called Verdun,
and then four to five the hills.
Bring your guns up there,
start shooting at the city of Verdun and
wait for the French army to show up and
try knock you off those hills.
And knowing the superiority of prepared
defenses,
the French are just going to bash
themselves up against your barbed wire,
your trenches,
your machine guns,
your cannon,
and everything else in a place that was
specifically designed to be a killing
field.
So thoroughly attritional bloody 20th
century,
way to conduct warfare,
but it's not a bad idea.
It also should be no surprise that a
battle that was designed to act like a
meat grinder turns into one of the most
horrible battles of all time.
Even the name,
when I hear it Verdun,
it's like Stalin Grad.
It really is.
It's one of those names that just
conjures up a specific image and,
and level of horror that puts it in a
special place in military history.
You know,
it's,
it's sort of like if you said,
you know,
where's the worst place in the world to
ever be in military history?
It's like a tie between a million
different spots,
right?
Mankind's had a long enough past so that
there are recurring examples of horrific
places to end up on any given day.
We like to cite the famous battle
between the Romans and the
Carthaginians.
Thousands of years ago,
Kenny were all those Romans were
surrounded and trapped and killed over
the whole long day.
I mean,
it's terrible,
but probably about as bad as a lot of
other terrible situations.
There's a few where you just go,
okay,
that's as bad as the battle of Kony sort
of.
But add artillery.
I mean Verdun is like nothing
that has ever happened really on a large
scale.
I'm sure.
Again,
mankind's long history,
everything's Kinda tried.
Nothing's new under the sun as they say,
but for dentists,
Special Verdun is so special,
in fact,
and so different and so outside the box
for the thinking of the time period that
when fall heightened comes up with the
idea that he's going to bleed France
white his words.
It's so runs against the grain of the
19th century,
sort of morality of warfare.
Remember we started this war a mere year
and a half ago wearing white gloves with
people who dewald when they were in
school together and who thought of this
in an almost,
especially on the western front,
Golan kind of sense,
right?
We should exchange swords when we
surrender and all this stuff,
and now we have generals thinking,
okay,
how can I lewer millions of men into a
confined space and just pound them into
Marmalade to quote one French soldiers
way of explaining what happened.
One of the things I love by the way
about this period,
just like I love it about the Second
World War,
is that we have a lot of the actual
words of the generals themselves.
They all wrote memoirs,
as we said after the war,
most of the time trying to defend their
reputation against their critics because
after this war,
everyone's pointing fingers at
everybody,
you know,
because it was so terrible and people
were so angry and so mad generals
amongst other people that they were
looking to blame.
Then all these generals would write
pieces defending their ideas.
We have faulconer Heinz,
we have looted and doors.
We have all these guy's memoir's now you
can't take them at face value.
Remember,
they're trying to stake out a historical
position here in defense of their own
historical reputation.
Nonetheless,
Falcon Nine,
you know,
and you either love fall behind or hate
him.
He has his fans and he has his
detractors.
I'm one of his fans.
I liked the way his mind works and the
way he writes in his book where he,
you know,
written right after the war where he's
trying to explain his thinking on this.
He runs down in logical fashion,
you know,
where he sees the war in 1915 and it's
not that bad for the central powers.
You'll hear a lot of people that will
say after the Germans failed with that
initial knockout blow in 1914,
it was all a hard slog downhill for
them.
Not Necessarily
Nineteen 15 was a good year for the
central powers.
They'll have some other attempts where
they'll almost win the war later in the
war.
So this is like,
as we've said all along the heavyweight
fight,
and there are times when both sides have
the other side in trouble.
A quick look at Fall Ghanaians Memoir
shows that he thinks Francis in trouble,
but it's not that far from the breaking
point.
Here's what Falcon Hind writes about,
his thinking leading up to his planning
for this battle that he's most known for
it for done.
Falcon hine writes,
quote,
as I've already insisted,
the strain on France has almost reached
the breaking point,
though it is certainly borne with the
most remarkable devotion.
If we succeeded in opening the eyes of
her people to the fact that in the
military sense they have nothing more to
hope for.
That breaking point would be reached and
England's best sword knocked out of her
hand to achieve that object.
The uncertain method of a massive
breakthrough in any case beyond our
means is unnecessary.
We can probably do enough for our
purposes with limited resources within
our reach behind the French sector of
the western front.
They are our objectives for the
retention of which the French general
staff would be compelled to throw in
every man they have.
If they do so,
the forces of France will bleed to death
as there can be no question of a
voluntary withdrawal,
whether we reach our goal or not.
And to quote
British military historian John Keegan
put it this way,
quote Falcon Heinz plan was brutally
simple.
The French forced to fight in a crucial
but narrowly constricted corner of the
western front would be compelled to feed
reinforcements into a battle of
attrition where the material
circumstances so favored the Germans.
That defeat was inevitable.
If the French gave up the struggle,
they would lose verdun.
If they persisted,
they would lose their army.
And to quote this plan of Falcon Heine
was given the sinister sounding name of
Operation Gallery,
which I've seen translated multiple
different ways.
Usually it's called operation judgment,
which implies a sort of finality that is
the high hope of fall behind going into
this campaign.
Maybe this will decide the war,
another translation you sometimes run
into his court of Justice.
Same sort of an idea,
a decision point.
The third translation though that you'll
sometimes run into is more indicative of
the tactics and approach that Falcon
Heights going to take to win this
battle.
It's operation place of execution and
while the Kaiser and fall behind and all
these generals are coming up with this
plan in late 1915,
the allies,
the entente forces are doing the same
thing and the allies a little bit
lackadaisical about the whole thing.
Not the Russians,
not the people in the Balkans had been
feeling German attacks over the last
year,
but the British and the French who
haven't seen the German army on the
offensive since way back in 1914.
They're kind of leisurely planning what
they think will probably be their war
winning giant offensive slated for late
spring or early summer,
1916 over on the river somme and
enormous joined British and French
effort with months of planning and and
just sweeping everything in front of
them.
That kind of rosy outlook and the
Germans instead in late February,
19,
16,
go on the offensive on the western front
for the first time in more than a year
and catch everyone off guard.
It's ridiculous that they could have the
amount of effort that was required to
put together a modern offensive is
something we modern people take for
granted,
but when you hear how much planning and
stockpiling and engineering feats are
required to pull off something like the
battle of Verdun,
you begin to see why it was so different
than anything these people had ever
known in the past.
As we said,
100 years before and Napoleonic battle
was considered extraordinary.
If it went on for three days throughout
most of human history battles take
hours.
These battles that these allied and
central power planners are conducting
require months of preparation.
They all go on for months to how do you
get enough stuff there to make sure your
soldiers don't starve or run out of
ammunition?
Well,
for the battle of Verdun,
it was more than seven weeks of actual
unloading of supplies.
Here's the way writer Gj Meyer describes
the planning and stockpiling before the
February 1916 battle quote,
the Germans.
Meanwhile,
we're accomplishing prodigious feats in
getting everything in place,
helped by the Heli,
wouldn't countryside,
and the cloudy winter weather of the
Verdun region.
They were doing an astonishingly good
job of keeping the French from learning
what they intended to do,
or when or even exactly were no fewer
than five new railway lines were
constructed across the German held
portion of the plateau immediately to
the east of the verdant hills in a seven
week period between late December and
early February,
trains,
not railway cars,
but entire trains hauled in two point 5
million shells,
earthmoving equipment,
construction machinery and everything
required to prepare the offensive and
support 300,000
troops in winter came rolling up to
Verdun.
The guns were positioned in the woods
and covered with camouflage and new
development in warfare made necessary by
aerial reconnaissance.
Underground chambers capable of holding
as many as $500,
million each.
We're escovedo opposite the French lines
and lined with steel and concrete in the
sky.
Above all,
this was the greatest concentration of
aircraft yet seen on any front 150
aircraft,
a German umbrella,
so impenetrable that even on the rare
days when visibility was good,
the French pilots were unable to get a
close look at what was happening.
By the second week of February,
everything was in place for an offensive
with the potential to change the course
of the war and the German plan was
complicated and it was complicated
because this was one of the great
defensive spots in French history for
Don wasn't just a fortress.
It was a fortress zone.
Multiple fortresses all working together
ground that had been fought over since
the day of Julius Caesar and the Romans
fortifications that had been upgraded.
Even as recently as 1914 when the
lessons of what happened to those
Belgian forts were incorporated,
and then when the war started,
the French high command decided that
fortresses we're old fashioned due to
the limits of new technology or rather
the lack of limits.
They decided that those Belgian forts
being pounded by,
that artillery signaled that these forts
were nothing but a death trap,
and it would be better to take the
weapons on them and the troops that man
them and put them to where the hotspots
were in the fighting.
After all,
if Francis in a life or death struggle,
what are we putting a 100,000
or more troops in the ridden region to
man a bunch of fortresses that are just
going to trap them and get them killed
by artillery.
Let's put them where they're needed.
Oh yeah.
Make sure they bring the guns and the
ammunition and everything else.
So they did for don was a relatively
relatively quiet sector in 1916 before
the big German buildup.
Nonetheless,
you can't hide preparations as extensive
as the German preparations for wherever
the French become aware of it a couple
of weeks before the Germans launch their
attack and are quickly trying to make up
for lost ground and get stuff,
you know,
to these areas because they can sense a
buildup.
And the Germans are launching,
um,
distracting attacks elsewhere to sort of
confused the French on where
everything's coming from.
And on February 21st after a couple of
postponements due to bad weather,
the storm breaks,
it's kicked off by a giant naval gun
whose nickname,
by the way,
as long Max,
just like naming swords,
got a name the guns to apparently and
long Max fires a shell that travels
somewhere between 15 and 20 miles.
These are enormous weapons.
And that becomes the first shelter drop
as part of the giant barrage that kicks
off the battle of Verdun.
And right after long Max is barrage
kicks off all these enormous weapons
open up.
See,
it's not just between 1200 to 1500 guns,
it's that half of them are huge.
You have all those guns that pounded the
fortunate Belgium,
those giant 420 millimeter gamma
mortars.
You had the 380 millimeter Skoda pieces
from Austria and you have more of each
of them.
And then you have an enormous number of
210 millimeters and,
and one seventies and 1:55.
And I mean my goodness,
and they open up all at once and begin
pounding this relatively small area of
the front.
What makes this so incredibly damaging
is do you have these huge weapons
pounding this relatively tiny area on a
map and you fire an enormous number of
shells by any standard,
the first world war in a short period of
time.
So if you're on the ground at some of
those 1915 battles and they're firing
one point 7 million shells,
but they're doing it over two or three
or four weeks,
the intensity on the ground is very
different than if they're firing 2
million shells in six days
over a tiny area.
One little wood on the battlefield,
a thousand yards by 500 yards,
took 80,000
shells in the first week.
What does that look like?
There's no human reference for this.
I'm going to try to picture.
I closed my eyes and I try to picture
forests disappearing in front of my
eyes.
This is heavily wooded,
forested,
hilly terrain and burden.
And right after the bombardment,
you know,
24 hours,
there's no forest laughed.
I've watched forests belonged over weeks
and months and it's still appalling to
wake up and more forest is gone.
What if you got to watch the entire
thing churned up in front of you in a
matter of hours,
like a giant celestial weed whacker and
chewing up grass.
There are accounts that say that,
you know,
you'd have the shelling is so intensive
to a giant tree,
would get blown up in the air and before
it lands on the ground again,
another shell hits it and blows it right
back up in the air.
A veteran said that the battlefield
quickly looked like an asparagus farm
with giant shoots shooting up all over
the soil everywhere,
which are the tree stumps and wood
everywhere.
Needless to say to me,
this is something I would have to have
some sort of video have to imagine when
I was a kid.
I used to wonder what a tsunami looked
like.
And um,
now of course we have video of that.
It was unimaginable when I was young.
Now it's something anyone who wants to
see it can go look up on youtube or
something.
That was a very rare sight and natural
phenomenon or a manmade phenomenon for
people to see.
Shelling is the same way,
and by the way,
there's a lot fewer accounts than you
might imagine of the first day shelling
at the battle of Verdun and,
um,
that's an English.
Then I'm sure there must be more German
and French,
but it's important to point out that
there aren't a lot of people that
probably survived the war in tact after
those battles.
And the ones who did were probably not
all that excited to relive the
experience.
We do have some things though,
even though it's 40 years old.
Alister Horns,
the price of glory has some of the best
accounts in English of what it was like
on the ground.
When the shelling started.
He tells one story of a corporal who is
with his buddies and they're just
grinding some coffee.
When the first shell start dropping,
he writes,
quote,
suddenly the whole world seemed to
disintegrate around him with the
condition to Alacrity of old soldiers.
The two men with the coffee grinder
disappeared below ground,
cursing and unprintable French.
Why couldn't the bastards wait until I'd
finished my coffee?
The air in the way that little forested
area,
they are seemed solid with whirling
material to Corporal Stephane.
It was as if it were swept by a quote
storm,
a hurricane attempt tempest growing ever
stronger where it was raining,
nothing but paving stones and quote Horn
continues,
quote upon the terrible dean of the
explosions were superimposed.
The splintering crashes of rending would
as the great 210 millimeter shells
lopped off branches or uprooted the
trees themselves,
barely had the tree trunks fallen.
Then they were spewed up into the air
again by fresh eruptions from his own
position,
still relatively immune to the shelling.
Stephane watched it's methodical,
progress with the certain macabre
fascination.
It was like a garden hose he thought and
quote,
and then he describes how the shells
would move like a wave from one location
to another,
pounding everything in between and then
methodically go back in the direction
that just came from as though it's
continually mowing the same piece of
ground over and over again.
It shows you what the plan had been
before they started to make sure every
inch of ground was covered.
German aircraft are flying over the
battlefield,
having knocked the French air force out
of the sky and are spotting for their
guns and keeping the French planes from
locating the German guns so the French
guns could shoot at them.
This leads to a very one sided initial
encounter.
Historian Polygon.
Koski compares the initial bombardment
here to the 1915 bottle of champagne,
which at the time seemed momentously
titanic.
That was a year ago.
Now,
a year later,
it seems like chump change compared to
what the first day at Verdun is sort of
priests aging.
Jen Koski writes quote,
it was partly because of such air cover,
partly because it enjoys such free rein
that morning that the German
shelling could exceed in intensity
anything the French or anyone else had
ever endured.
This was the bottle of champagne
multiplied 10 times over,
but where the difference in kind as
well,
the German artillerist were blanketing
entire zones with their shells.
They directed their fire not merely onto
positions they wished to take or onto
lines they wish to obliterate,
but into all that nature had grown and
that man had erected as well,
making up in density for what they
lacked in precision that day.
They saturated successive zones within a
25 mile arc between albacore on the left
bank and attained on the right bank of
the Muse with a million high explosive
shells of the heaviest caliber known
demand,
200 8,305,
380,
even 420 millimeters wide and with
lesser shells bearing toxic gases as
well method rather than rage.
The system of the power hammer rather
than the obstinacy of the battering ram
drove the destruction,
the morbid calculus per se,
aged the carpet bombing of later wars
that would raise entire cities and
ignite entire landscapes.
But for now the thought was purely
tactical to devastate so that the
infantry could infiltrate
into quote.
Now,
as Jen Koski says,
the difference in this artillery barrage
is not just in the amount of stuff,
but the way they do it.
I mean,
they're employing every little trick
that they've learned in the last year,
year and a half of warfare,
including one that they probably think
it was a clever enhancement.
I'm sure the British and the French must
have thought it.
Another example of deviousness on the
German part,
but the Germans start this artillery
barrage,
you know,
a little after seven in the morning and
they pound these French positions all
morning and into the lunchtime hour,
and then they stop at midday.
They stop on Cue all at once.
Now even to the punch,
drunk French survivors on the receiving
end of the worst artillery barrage and
human history.
Know what this means.
It always means the same thing.
It means the German ground troops are
coming in an offensive.
That's why you stopped shooting so that
you don't blow your own men up.
Now that they're on the way,
right?
So the French runup to their positions,
they man,
their defensive spots,
they uncover any guns they've got hit
and they get ready to push back the
German assault.
Now that it's coming,
except that it isn't coming.
It's a trick and all of a sudden all the
guns opened up again and start smashing
the now exposed French survivors who
show those planes up in the air among
other observers.
Oh yeah.
That guy's revived.
Oh,
there's a machine gun nest we didn't
see.
It was an intermission to get the French
to expose themselves and this shelan
goes for the rest of the day until the
late afternoon,
so from seven something in the morning
to force something in the afternoon,
and then the French survivors see the
first signs of German infantry activity
approaching what they see looks like
something out of a time machine from the
hitlarian Arab gone are the iconic
pickle.
How by the pointed helmets that the
German troops were that hearkened back
to the greatness of Prussia in Europe at
the height of its 19th century,
sort of colonial dominance.
It's symbolic and it's been replaced
with something that looks like a minor
should wear it
thoroughly working class,
nothing romantic,
gentlemanly officer or a risk socratic
about it.
These tip of the spear troops here are
wearing the German style helm,
which with a minor modification or two
is the exact same helmet the German
troops will were in the Second World
War.
These storm troopers,
as they're called and have been known to
history,
look like the Wehrmacht and they're
carrying flame throwers among other
nasty surprises for anyone.
They might run into the gun machine guns
with them.
They got men who are wearing clothes
that have big bags sort of as part of
the where they can stuff hand grenades
because you just can't carry enough hand
grenades when you need them.
They've even got in this,
you know,
shows you what they think.
They're up against melee weapons with
them.
I mean they're famous.
All these storm troop type units are
famous for the clubs they carry or the
hatchets or the long knives or even
things like brass knuckles and stuff.
These are people who expect to get into
physical combat at very close range.
They are using what at the time seemed
like very new fangled,
very modern techniques on the
battlefield.
They're known as infiltration tactics.
They pretty much are the same small unit
tactics every military in the world uses
today.
They've been in development for a while
too.
It's a myth to suggest that the first
time anybody sees them as with these
storm troops,
but these storm troops are the first to
integrate everything into their system
here.
Not only are they going to use these
infiltration tactics,
but look at the weapons that they've
armed themselves with and they've
trained with all this.
In other words,
they've integrated all the various ideas
and theories from all the militaries
around the world for the last 15 years
and are the first to put these troops
out in the field whose job it is to look
for weak spots and they call them the
field and when they run into,
you know,
significant opposition,
they stop or move around it in places
where everyone's been killed by the
artillery barrage they punched right
through there.
Their goal is to capture bait.
Remember,
this is a trap.
The cheese in the trap has to be
captured by the Germans before it can
play the role of cheese.
That's what this is all about.
That is,
if you believe,
you know,
the standard historical approach,
this quite a few historians who believe
this whole idea of let's create this
meat grinder is bs propaganda at the
time.
And um,
you know,
mia culpa avoidance later on,
right?
If you believe that they're not trying
to capture bait,
they're trying to capture her done
either way.
The
point of this initial attack is to get
the heights.
The problem is the Germans find out to a
degree exactly what the French and the
British had found out the whole year
before,
which is that no matter how good the
artillery barrage,
there are just units that survive.
And then when they strike back at you,
it's amazing and the casualties mounted
up unbelievably fast.
On the very first day as the German
troops pour into an area and begin to
coalesce and sort of muster in us in a,
in a specific area,
French artillery opens up on them.
And this is an account by a French staff
officer with the artillery who first
describes what the German artillery
attack on his positions is like,
and then describes responding in kind
his was one of the few batteries that
did by the way he writes,
quote,
thousands of projectiles are flying in
all directions,
some whistling,
others howling,
others moaning,
low and all uniting into one infernal
roar from time to time and Ariel torpedo
passes,
making a noise like a giant motor car
with a tremendous thud,
a giant shell bursts quite close to our
observation post,
breaking the telephone wire and
interrupting all communication with our
batteries.
A man gets out at once for repairs,
crawling along his stomach through all
this place of bursting minds and shells,
it seems quite impossible.
He writes that he should escape the rain
of shells which exceeds anything
imaginable.
There has never been such a bombardment
and war.
Our man seems to be envelops and
explosions and shelters himself from
time to time in the shell craters which
honeycomb the ground.
Finally,
he reaches a less stormy spot,
men's his wires,
and then as it would be madness to try
to return,
settles down in a big crater and waits
for the storm to pass.
Now he looks up and sees the German
assaults.
Approaching quote beyond in the valley,
dark masses are moving over the snow
covered ground.
It is German infantry advancing impact
formation along the valley to the
attack.
They look like a big gray carpet being
unrolled over the country.
We telephone through to the batteries
and the ball begins.
The site is hellish in the distance in
the valley and upon the slopes,
regimens spread out and as they deploy,
fresh troops come pouring in,
there's a whistle over our heads.
It's our first shell.
It falls right in the middle of the
enemy infantry.
We telephone through telling our
batteries of their hit and a delusion of
heavy shells is poured on the enemy.
Their physician becomes critical through
glasses.
We can see men,
maddened men covered with earth and
blood falling one upon the other.
When the first wave of the assault is
decimated,
the ground is dotted with heaps of
corpses,
but the second wave is already pressing
on once more.
Our shells carve awful gaps in their
ranks.
Nevertheless,
like an army of rats,
the bushes continue to advance in
spite of our Mar Mites,
a term the French use for their shells.
He says,
quote,
than our heavy artillery burst forth.
In theory,
the whole valley is turned into a
volcano and it's exit is stopped by the
barrier of the slain and quote.
That's a foretaste of what's to come
right there.
The Germans have to be on the offensive
for a little while in this battle,
a battle that is probably built upon the
presumption that the defense has a huge
advantage on the offense.
This artillery was meant to make up for
some of that,
but the Germans are taking higher than
expected losses from minute one.
This is a problem too,
because remember,
regardless of which historical school
you adhere to on the point of this
battle,
it was always part of the plan to lose
as few people as possible.
So the Germans are concerned with losses
and part of the reason they're suffering
so many is the French are resisting
heroically on these first few days.
There are units that surrender,
there are units that are just gone from
the artillery barrage,
but there are units including elite
ones,
but also rather pedestrian.
One's sitting there and dying to the
last man to delay this German advance.
These infiltration troops are looking
for places to push through.
They find a couple,
but they find a bunch with these
decimated defenders resisting heroically
to buy the country.
Time to get fresh troops reinforcing
that area to that area of Verdun is
actually supplied on the French side by
one little teeny road.
The Germans had built multiple railway
lines and their site to supply the
battlefield.
Right?
So as French reinforcements are coming
up,
these heroic defenders are holding the
Germans off as long as they can.
There are more big bombardments that
Germans push more troops in with more
tenacity.
On February 25th,
the Germans in an almost Indiana Light
Jones movie kind of drama capture the
big fort in this region.
That's sort of overlooks the whole
battlefield and we told you that the
French high command kind of lost
interest in force after the Germans and
smashed the ones in Belgium and smash
the early ones in France,
but they still had people in them and
there were still guns in them and slowly
but surely they were starting to realize
that sometimes and in some places they
were worth having,
didn't matter.
These troops were in this fort,
which is mostly below ground.
When a German soldier gets blown into it
somehow due to a shell exploding nearby,
lands down on the ground,
has a pistol with him and eventually
will lead in some friends,
but by and large is walking around this
underground giant fort and as he opens
doors into rooms,
there's a couple of French soldiers
playing cards or whatever and he
captures them and locked them in a room
and he does this over and over and over
again.
He finally has everybody Kinda captured.
Nobody dies on either side and this
major feature in the early part of the
battle falls to the Germans.
It's one of those situations that sort
of rocks the French morale and they to
fall apart.
They've been through eight ton and now
there's this crisis moment where all of
a sudden it looks like the Germans are
going to break through in the French are
just going to fall apart before any
reinforcements can stiffen the line.
This is where things get really wiggy in
this battle.
By the way,
it gets right down to what the hell.
The point of it is.
If you're a falcon hein and the
historians who think he's trying to
create a meat grinder fall,
that's true.
You don't want to break through.
You don't want Verdun.
It's not really what you want.
It's the cheese in your trap.
If you take it,
then you're just going to get
counterattack and you're going to lose a
lot of troops again and that then that's
19,
15 all over again.
What did we do differently?
Right?
If you're from the other school of
thought though,
the idea of breaking through to Verdun
at this point is to nearly achieved what
the whole battle was designed to do
unexpectedly quickly.
The crown prince who's commanding those
armies really excited and there's all
sorts of messages where they say,
Oh,
I will take it.
I mean,
didn't expect it this fast,
but we'll take it and then they get
within two miles of the city at one
point and then the French put a new
commander in charge.
A guy who will be famous by the way in
both world wars for different reasons.
A guy named Pattan
and pitocin becomes,
you know,
it's so hard to,
to separate the myth from the man when
he,
with his connection to Verdun.
But the narrative is that baton gets in
there and changes the French morale by
himself.
Practically.
There's all these generals traveled with
their own press corps.
So there's going to be,
this guy is going to have a bunch of
people helping to,
to pump up the myth,
but he's famous for coming to the
battlefield and you know,
in these situations where the French
just look desperate,
you know,
looking at troops and going,
now we have them.
We got them right where we want them.
That kind of thing.
And you know,
maybe it's the 19th century mentality,
but that seems to work.
They famously says,
or somebody says for him,
and then he stands behind it.
They shall not pass.
And this becomes the big narrative of
redundant.
It turns into like a French thermopylae,
but the French aren't going to die to
the last man.
They're going to win in the end,
right?
It's again,
part of this,
this overriding narrative.
Now,
morale is kind of a hard to quantify as
sort of thing,
hard to measure,
hard to look back in history and prove
anything.
You don't have to prove the real world
terrafirma things that Bhutan did.
Buttons and artillery guy,
he's a defensive specialist and the
first thing he does is bringing his own
artillery and consolidate it and asked
for more and slowly but surely begins to
build up his own meat grinder for two
can play at that game and Pitocin,
start stocking up the French side with
our chiller re to.
And all this artillery turns this entire
area into the moon.
But weirder these shell holes in your
head.
You think of something symmetrical like
an immediate right crater.
But it doesn't happen that way because
you get these shell holes,
which can be 30 feet deep with
absolutely straight up and down edges,
but then they get hit with another shell
at some weird angle or an on an edge and
then they get hit with another one and
another one and another one,
and it turns it into super weird
formations.
It still looks weird today.
If you go look at modern pictures of the
verdant battlefield,
it looks totally alien and it creates a
battlefield.
There's a painting by a Frenchman Larue
I think is his name,
called hell,
and it shows a couple of French soldiers
in one of these craters and a dead body
near them and they're wearing gas masks
and the barrage is going on in giant
timbers are part of this enormous crater
and craters everywhere in the distance
as far as you look.
We said this is like making war worse
and these craters are the grossest thing
you can imagine.
I mean really just awful.
They fill with water very quickly.
Every one of them practically with a
dead body or two in them,
they fill with water.
There's tons of trash,
tons of stuff.
I'm all kinds of.
I mean they're mostly used as latrines.
If it's close enough to where you can
get to them.
The water is fed ID and horrible and
Greasy from the bloated bodies that
float in it and interestingly enough
poisonous because the gas that's used on
these battlefields,
I know it's tempting to think of it as
vapor,
but it's really almost a solid where
when a gas shell explodes,
it covers an entire area with like a
pollen like coding and that pollen.
Light coding is deadly,
so it's like putting insecticide on a
given area to keep you out of it for
awhile and eventually the rain will come
and dissolve that,
but the dissolve runoff goes into all
these shell holes that are filled with
water and makes them just poisonous.
There will be a writer who will talk
about how at first in in the spring,
the Verdun battlefield,
we'll try to recover a little of its
life and they will see little green
shoots pop up for a minute before the
poisonous air and soil and water and
everything just kills them right away.
It's a giant burnt out insecticide zone.
That's what Verdun is and and the,
the landscape itself is horrifying to a
degree that's hard to describe unless
you want to say that this is more door.
This is Jrr tolkien's conception of the
dark land.
I mean,
he was in the first world war.
Maybe he got it from there.
The match is perfect though.
I mean once they start to.
Hillary has been going for not even that
long at this levels of intensity you
have around you on this battlefield and
we talked about stage and all the people
merely players will look at this stage.
These people are playing on,
you know,
very shortly into the battle.
It's a lunar landscape.
It's the moon.
Okay.
And these trenches are places where
people meet their end very often.
I mean lots of stories about soldiers
with big heavy packs in the night,
losing their way,
falling into one of these terrible
craters and just
drowning.
The worst stories are these people who
you know,
you hear stories by people drinking,
kneeling down and drinking out of these
green colored poisonous waters with
bodies floating in it because the water
isn't making it up to the front.
The people whose job it is to bring food
and water to the people on the front
edge of the meat grinder are getting
killed,
trying to bring it up.
This is a terrible battle.
It's the battle of 1915 taken to the
next level,
which is what this war is going to be
about.
Every time the world thinks they've come
to the limits of their endurance,
surely this is the worst battle there
will ever be.
The standard gets up again and this
happens continually.
It's a pressure cooker.
It's who's going to break first and you
know you thought last year was bad.
Welcome to next year and while next year
is deadlier and while the scale is more
and perhaps unsustainably titanic,
the pattern is unfortunately for the
troops on the ground horrifically
familiar,
about a week into the assault,
the German attack at Verdun stalls.
Just like all these other battles we've
seen in a lot more,
we will see the initial assault is the
most tense nail biting up in the air
kind of time.
Once it stopped,
there may be ebbs and flows and scary
moments,
but by and large we have descended into
what Churchill call did he say prolonged
operations or extended operations.
We're now into combat and for the troops
on the ground,
it's the most horrifying environment.
When we want to study the idea of what
human beings can do,
it seems to me you want to see them in
some of the most.
If you want to see,
just like a product test,
did you want to put it under the most
extreme stress and see how it behaves.
Look at what Verdun becomes over the
next many months.
For the people on the ground who have to
live this.
How do they endure?
And when you hear the stories from this
place,
I mean start with the approach.
March the French,
as we've said,
spend a lot of trouble to rotate their
troops in and out of this battle because
they get worn down like a pencil and a
pencil sharpener,
so you have to rotate them.
When the soldiers approach Verdun,
they can see it along way away.
I mean the guns of the opening barrage
were said to be audible a hundred miles
away,
so when they're approaching verdant,
it looks like a giant forest fire in the
distance.
One French soldier on the way to it said
that it reminded him of a gigantic forge
that ceased neither day or night,
and to quote it's the fires are more
door,
like I said,
and then all of a sudden the air becomes
smokey and hazy and you don't see the
sun clearly anymore and all the
vegetation disappears.
One artist said the only color in the
landscape after a while because it's
just overturned dirt and bodies and and
churned up concrete.
It's a hellish environment,
but there is a smear of red here or
there where the horses have just been
splattered by artillery.
Have I mentioned that?
It sounds like hell yet.
We mentioned earlier how hard it was to
get food and water to the troops
fighting at the front line,
but it was hard to get anything to the
troops fighting at the front line,
for example,
to get new troops to the front line
could kill off half your troops in his
book the price of glory.
Alistair horn
takes a couple of different accounts and
puts them together and quotes a few
people who were there about what it was
like simply trying to get to the front
of the meat grinder at Verdun.
Imagined suffering in a 40 or 50 percent
casualties trying to get to the meat
grinder.
Here's what he writes.
I'm quote,
a mile or two from the front line.
Troops entered the first communication
trenches though to call them.
This was generally both an exaggeration
and an anachronism.
Parapets gradually grew lower and lower
until the trench became little deeper
than a roadside ditch.
Shells now began to fall with increasing
regularity among closely packed men in
the darkness.
He says,
for obvious reasons,
approach marches were usually made at
night.
The columns trampled over,
the howling wounded that lay under a
foot.
Suddenly the trench became nothing more
than a track hardly traced out amid the
shell holes in the mud,
which the shelling had now turned to a
consistency of sticky butter.
Troops stumbled and fell repeatedly
cursing in low undertones as if fearful
of being overheard by the enemy who
relentlessly pursued them with uh,
shells at every step.
Sometimes there were duck boards around
the lips of the huge shell craters,
but more often there were not,
and heavily laden men falling into the
water.
Filled holes remained there until they
drowned,
unable to crawl up the greasy sides.
If a comrade pause to lend a hand,
he writes,
it often meant that too would drowned
instead of one in the chaos of the
battlefield.
We're all reference points had long
since been obliterated.
Relieving detachments often got lost and
wandered hopelessly all night,
only to be massacred by an enemy.
Machine gunner is dawn betrayed them.
It was not unusual for reliefs to reach
the front line with only half the
numbers that set out,
nor for this nightmare approach march to
last 10 hours or longer.
And quote seems to me,
maybe I can speak for some of my
generation if I just spent 10 hours
struggling through that and lost half
our people while doing so.
Just so I got to take my turn on the
front lines.
I'm going to be severely
these stabilized,
let's put it that way.
Is that a good way to describe it?
And even though these French units will
be rotated,
maybe only spent five or six or seven
days up at the front,
I mean,
that was designed to keep them from just
being and being shattered.
But judging from some of the witness
accounts,
uh,
it didn't work very well.
British historian John Keegan delayed
John Keegan a rights that a French
officer named Augustine coaching spent
from the ninth to the 14th of April on
one of these important hills and Keegan
rights quoting this officer quote,
the last two days soaked in icy mud
under terrible bombardment without any
shelter other than the narrowness of the
trench.
The Bosch did not attack naturally.
It would have been too stupid result.
I arrived there with 175 men.
I returned with 34 several half mad,
not replying anymore.
When I spoke to them and quote,
a French lieutenant described watching a
unit,
his own unit actually coming down and
back from Verdun after being relieved
and he says,
quote first came the skeletons of
companies occasionally led by a wounded
officer leaning on a stick,
all marched or rather advanced in small
steps,
zigzagging as if intoxicated.
It was hard to tell the color of their
faces from that of their tunics.
Mud had covered,
everything dried off,
and then another layer had been
reapplied.
They said nothing.
They'd even lost the strength to
complain.
It seemed as if these mute faces were
crying,
something terrible,
the unbelievable horror of their
martyrdom.
Some territorials who were standing near
me became pensive.
They had that air of sadness that comes
over.
One one,
a funeral passes by and I overheard one
say it's no longer an army.
Those are corpses to have the
territorials wept in silence like women
and to quote,
so what's going on to those guys that
they go in one way and they come out so
shattered and sometimes it only takes a
couple of days to go from one reality to
the other.
That's where you know these firsthand
accounts from these people are so
moving.
First of all,
from the perspective of these men on the
ground,
everything seems so pointless because
they only know this little world of this
big battlefield they're operating on and
a perfect example is how you know these
generals were now fighting over the same
terrain,
features over and over and over month
after month after month.
They take them and then they're retaken
and then they take them again and
they're all fighting over the same
carnage,
stained ground over and over again,
and they develop names.
I mean,
one of these hills is hill three.
Oh,
four becomes a famous hill with a lot of
people paying with their lives to take
it and retake it again.
There's another one known as the dead
man or dead man's hills and other way to
translate it.
And that's another one of these hills.
Um,
I mean they've had the tops blasted all
off them by both sides.
Artillery there smoking like volcanoes
pretty much at all times.
We're told sort of a dual mount doom if
we want to keep our more door analogy
going.
And when a unit retakes a position on,
for example,
one of those long fought over terrain
features,
then you have that around you.
I mean,
for example,
I'm in passing him has several quotes
where he talks about soldiers having to
retake this ground that are nothing more
than sort of open cemeteries combined
with butcher shops.
And he writes,
quote on the ground,
soldier and writers,
Jack Meyer describes the real
rightfulness when he noted,
quote everywhere there were distended
bodies that your feet sank into the
stench of death,
hung over the jumble of decaying corpse
is like some hellish perfume and quote,
passing him continues quote,
when the Germans captured hill three,
oh,
four in May,
one of the first demands of the assault
troops was for a double ration of
tobacco to mask the overwhelming reek of
corpses routing around them.
Like Jacques Meyer,
a fellow French soldier wrote at this
time that quote,
quoting this French soldier now,
we all had on us the stench of dead
bodies,
the bread we ate,
the stagnant water.
We drank everything we touched how to
rotten smell,
owing to the fact that the earth around
us was literally stuffed with corpses.
And quote,
how do you not lose your mind?
French barrel maker and Corporal Louis
Bartos arrives at the famous hill three,
oh four at one point in this bottle and
looks up and contemplates this piece of
ground that is cost.
So many people on both sides there,
earthly existence.
He writes,
quote,
I looked out upon this famous nameless
hill,
our trench lay at the foot of it for
several months.
The hell had been disputed as if it had
diamond mines on it slopes,
alas,
all it contained now with thousands of
shredded pulverized corpses.
Nothing distinguished it from
neighboring hills.
It seemed to have been partly wooded at
one time,
but no trace of vegetation remained.
The convulsed overturned.
Earth offered nothing but a spectacle of
devastation and quote.
Now eventually in for reasons that we'll
get into in a minute,
the situation changes at for Don and the
Germans go from essentially a sort of an
offensive position to a defensive one as
they transfer forces to another part of
their front for something else that's
going on,
taking their attention and so the French
use this as an opportunity to retake
ground and now we get the same kind of
battles we had when the Germans were
moving forward in this.
Now that the French are and now the
Germans had taken a bunch of their
artillery away.
So now the French have the artillery
dominance and now the Germans get to
experience what the French experienced
on the other side and you know,
nine or 10 months into this battle,
we have human beings living on the edge
of what human beings can tolerate.
There's an extended,
a pair of quotes from the same guy,
a German soldier who is in of these
faults and these faults.
They're all over this area.
This is a fortified zone.
They have several Ford's covering one
another and a lot of the most terrible
battles happen over these forts and
they're battered down so that they're
just shells of what they were,
but they could still hold hundreds of
men and protect them from shrapnel.
So oftentimes you had tons of men in
these underground blown up forts with
blood everywhere and everything else.
And here's the way the environment is
described by this German soldier quote.
His name is private William Harmon's,
by the way,
of the 67th infantry regiment.
And I get this from Peter Hart's book,
the Great War.
He said,
quote,
the entrance was a mere hole in the
scarred battlefield and the silhouettes
of cowering men constantly crawling into
rod looked like huge ants in the dark.
I descended an iron ladder some 40 feet
into the concrete cavern.
It was an enormous place,
crowded with many hundreds of soldiers.
Some lay on bunk,
sleeping,
snoring and moaning,
some cluttered the passages between the
bunks,
chatting or writing letters,
other set or Nelton corners,
packing or unpacking their belongings.
Here,
a flashlight there,
a candle match your cigarette,
dotted the dark with flickering islands
of light continually shifting and
brightness from this subterranean
stronghold.
A small patch of sky could be seen when
one stood close to the iron ladder or
look through the shaft which contained
the ventilator fans occurrent of warm,
stale air from 40 feet beneath,
brought to my nostrils the sickening
smell of first aid medications.
Every one of the chicken wire births
were filled with mutilated,
muddy,
torn,
and befallen uniforms.
A dismal site.
There was a man with closed eyes,
a blood soaked bandage around his head,
another beside him lay twisting in pain.
I saw some lights written.
Men who would scratch their bandages off
to ease the itching.
The passages between the bunks were
crowded.
There must have been a thousand men
there,
some had been relieved,
but could not withdraw to the rear and
some who had come to relieve the others
could not proceed to the front lines.
All were imprisoned deep within the
concrete and rock entrails and the
quote.
Now,
that's a scene that up until that point
could have happened in a lot of wars.
What happens next in that underground
environment that that soldiers writing
from is something that on a large scale
between great powers only happened in
this war.
He says,
quote,
I heard the cry,
poison gas,
and I saw people around me putting on
their gas masks.
I adjusted mine,
which still hung over my shoulder.
There it was a yellowish gas glimmering
near the iron ladder.
A gas bomb must have been thrown into
the entrance shaft.
The CRI gas masks on electrified.
The whole shelter soldiers ran to get
their masks,
which they had hung on the walls and in
the corners or laid on their packs.
Many who had lost their is on the
battlefield,
began to cough,
the wounded in the bunks tried to climb
into the upper births while beneath the
gas crept forward along its way,
extinguishing candle.
After another,
soon many were dying and the bunks and
floors were filled with bodies over
which the living stepped and stumbled in
search of air.
The alarm surge like away from bunk to
bunk.
Before long it had reached the farthest
man 100 yards away.
The panic was so great that I saw badly
wounded men throw themselves onto the
floor as though they wanted to drink in
the gas while others tour the masks from
their neighbors faces.
Some had a reddish foam oozing from
their mouths and quote.
I always try to remind myself when we're
talking about these big grand battles
that what this really is is a million
stories like that.
The pain of that incident magnified over
the entire scope of the war.
And while I'm sure there's some people
who are harder than I am in terms of,
you know,
saying that that's life and that's what
history is filled with and all those
kinds of things.
It's hard not to sit there and feel a
sense of all.
I think for the people who faced this
and not out of any sort of patriotic,
you know,
glorification of war or anything else,
as I said,
just sort of the unexpectedly strong
limits of human endurance.
How did they sustain this effort?
How did they,
when told they had to advance into this
or just not run away at top speed.
How did they do it?
And let's acknowledge that not all of
them did.
There were a lot of people shot in this
war for running away,
but the large majority of them did not.
And you sit there and go,
how did they not rebel?
How did they not revolt?
What would we do today?
There's a great quote from a f Scott
Fitzgerald novel.
It's fictional,
but he puts words into the mouth of a
man who showing one of these 1916
battlefields to his compatriots there
touring the battlefield and he has a
discussion with him and he tries to
explain to them the almost soup that was
required to bring up a generation of
people who could do this.
In other words,
it's not just yours truly wondering how
people sustain this effort.
Even right after the war,
people were trying to figure out how
people could do this and here's the
section from the f Scott Fitzgerald
novel where Fitzgerald character
explains it and he points in the
distance to a little body of water and
says,
quote,
see that little stream?
We could walk to it in two minutes.
It took the British a month to walk to
it.
A whole empire walking very slowly,
dying in front and pushing forward
behind and another empire walked very
slowly backward,
a few inches a day,
leaving the dead like a million bloody
rugs.
No Europeans will ever do that again in
this generation and the other character
says,
why?
They've only just quit over in Turkey
and in Morocco.
The response quote,
that's different,
this western front business couldn't be
done again,
not for a long time.
The young men think they could do it,
but they couldn't.
They could fight the first modern again,
but not this.
This took religion and years of plenty
and tremendous sureties and the exact
relation that existed between the
classes.
The Russians and Italians weren't good
on this front.
You had to have a whole sold sentimental
equipment going back further than you
could remember.
You had to remember Christmas and
postcards of the crown prince and his
fiance and little cafes and valance and
beer gardens and entertain Linden and
weddings at the Murray and going to the
Derby and your grandfather's whiskers.
General grant invented this kind of
battle at Petersburg.
In 65 came the reply,
meaning general grant in the civil war
in 18,
65,
the main character says quote.
No,
he didn't.
He just invented mass butchery.
This kind of battle was invented by
Lewis Carroll and Jules Verne and
whoever wrote Ondine and country deacons
bowling and Marianne's in Marsay and
girls seduced in the back lanes of
Wittenberg and Westphalia.
Why?
This was a love battle.
There was a century of middleclass love
spent here and quote a century of middle
class love spent here that is profound
and that's how the generation that lived
through this war side,
so basically fitzgerald answer to that
question of,
you know,
how did these people endure is that you
had to have grown up the way they did
with the same cultural influences and
expectations,
including societal and class based ones
either had to have seen the world the
way they did,
had similar concepts of,
you know,
duty and expectations and even manhood
and you'd have to have in some ways the
same illusions to because in certain
circumstances having illusions could
help you carry out military operations
that people who were more cynical and
realistic would never do.
And you know,
when you think about the endurance to.
I mean it's so normal to focus on the
horrific war side of this.
But the simple life part of this is
sometimes what pushes people over the
edge.
You know,
you'll hear stories sometimes were they
will say,
well,
they were able to adapt to the shelling.
They just couldn't handle the rats or
something.
Something gets to them sometimes above
and beyond what you might think.
I mean,
a perfect example is start looking at
what day to day life was like for these
people who any of us would think we're
focused on staying alive,
but sometimes it got down to even more
base level than that.
Louis Bartos fighting in the Verdun
inferno writes about at night being in
one of trenches.
When the rain
just comes pouring down,
he says,
quote,
we were crouching down so it's not to
catch a stray bullet or shell fragment
passing by,
and if this weren't bad enough,
a heavy rain started to fall.
It didn't take long for the water to
fill in the ditch and to submerge our
shoes.
Our helmets were transformed into drain
spouts.
Little waterfalls ran down our packs
onto our hips,
off our shoulders and along our arms.
We didn't know what or whom we were
waiting for.
The night was pitch black where they
just going to leave us stuck in the
sewer
and quote.
Sewer is such an apt name too,
besides the bodies and the poison and
the decay and the lice and the rats have
not even dealt with them.
They're both absolutely beyond
imagination.
Living with the lions,
living with the rats.
You also have the problems of men
fighting in an inferno.
We're getting out of your trench meant a
pretty good chance of dying when you
have to go to the bathroom.
Louis parked us writes quote,
and to make it worse,
as I've already described,
all of us,
one after the other,
suffered from an epidemic of intestinal
disorders.
The resulting diarrhea sure cleaned us
out,
but in opportunity,
as soon as one of us got over at his
next door,
neighbor was afflicted with it and had
the bad luck to have to climb out of the
trench and head for the shell hole which
served as our latrine.
Of course,
we did this only in the last resort at
the last moment of agony,
stretching our guts until they were
about to burst.
One of us was surprised in the latrine
by one of these sudden fusel aids and
collapsed into his own excrement.
So as not to expose oneself to similar
incidents,
some used sardine or monkey meat cans as
chamber pots,
so it was not to have to leave.
One's hold in the ground,
won't even sacrificed his cast iron
dinner plate
end quote.
How do you keep your sanity?
You have to risk your life to I'm in the
whole thing again.
Ellen,
in Lincolnshire Battlefield,
there might've been one horrible day
where if you're unlucky enough to have
dysentery that day,
it's a horrible day in the ranks.
It isn't a day after day after day
thing.
These people are putting up with a
pounding on their psyche,
but understanding what they went through
is in large part what makes this story
so incredibly compelling.
The extremes of human experience,
right?
I talk about it all the time.
There's a wonderful paragraph by
historian Eric Dorn,
Bros who tries to describe why this
isn't gratuitous to talk about this,
why it's part of being astounded by your
ancestors.
Here's what
Bros says,
quote,
most historians today depart from the
traditional practice of omitting
casualty figures.
What was once left out for respect of
the dead and to avoid any indecent hint
of criticizing or questioning the
sacrifices they made is now included in
order to eliminate the magnitude of the
horror men faced by citing numbers.
In other words,
historians the process of turning back
towards describing what war was really
like,
and they do this despite the
understandable loading of the veterans
themselves to remember or speak about
traumatic experiences they have tried
usually unsuccessfully to suppress the
problems historians encounter with
casualty figures.
However,
especially the astronomical numbers of
dead and wounded in 20th century wars is
that numbers have a numbing quality to
them.
Although shocking to read initially,
they quickly lose descriptive
effectiveness as mines fail to grasp
horror in the abstract,
in order to do historical justice to
combat on the ground.
Therefore,
it is necessary to go beyond the numbers
to the gruesome eyewitness accounts,
shaking off criticism that to go there
is gratuitous.
The Great War can only be fully
understood if all its aspects are
exposed.
Dimensions of the front experience that
not only affected soldiers' morale and
eventually the outcome of the war,
but also home fronts and they are
critically important to willingness to
continue shouldering the war effort.
All wars are horrible.
Bros writes tragedies for the dead,
their relatives and friends hobbling,
sometimes disfiguring injuries for
others,
turning wives,
children and parents and the caregivers
for life and psychological mind fields
for veterans who may have escaped death
and injury,
but not the terrible memories with which
loved ones too are then forced to live.
The Great War was especially helacious.
However,
because it was the first to unleash the
full mechanized fury of sophisticated
industrial technology and quote,
men had never been asked to endure
anything quite like this.
Some of these French soldiers had to go
back to verdun more than one time.
What does that do to you?
I read somewhere where one of them said
the first time you can kind of handle
because you don't know what you're in
for.
It's particularly hard when you're going
back to more door after you've been to
more door,
so happy to have survived and now you
get to take your chances all over again,
so the majority of the French army gets
a chance to rotate through this area at
least once and they never get over.
It.
Pattan himself will say about the Verdun
experienced to the French army quote,
the constant visions of death had
penetrated the French soldier with a
resignation that bordered on fatalism
and quote,
the fighting wind end for 10 months.
About half that time the Germans were on
the attack.
The other half the time the French were
on the attack and by the time it was
over,
this is disputed,
but about a million total casualties.
Both sides added up together,
give or take 200,000.
Either way at the end of the war,
it will be mandated in the treaty that
win.
This battle field is cleared and it will
take decades just to get the bodies off
of it.
The shells are still there and many of
these areas are cordoned off until,
well,
probably
a good 100,
200 years from now.
I'm the treaty stipulated that when
French bodies were dug up and buried,
they needed to be buried singularly and
with white crosses for purity.
The Germans didn't have to be in a
single grave and their graves were to
carry black crosses signifying shame.
The depth of emotion that Verdun created
in the immediate post war generation,
but even in France today is unlike quite
any other military endevor French arms
have participated in
and the mythmaking about this crazy
battle starts before the fighting's even
done and there's a whole group of
revisionist historians who've been
trying ever since the battle happened to
poke holes in the myths that obscure the
reality of her done.
It's got such a sacred hold on both
France and Germany.
It's hard to separate the facts from the
fiction and there's a huge amount of
heroism and sacrifice connected to this
event.
It's understandable that you would get,
you know,
some mythmaking and the revisionist
historians often portray Falcon high and
the German commander.
And the one behind this plan as an
idiot,
it was dumb plan executed in competently
and after the war,
when people went to Falcon,
heightened said,
what were you thinking there?
He said,
oh,
I was trying to kill a lot of people.
That was my goal.
Mission accomplished a lot of these
revisionist historians.
I'm Paul Koski is a perfect example.
We'll say something like,
to make verdun out to be any worse than
any number of terrible world war one.
Battles is to play into the myth.
I mean,
he says,
if,
if being in a trench with the rain
falling on you with your feet up to your
knees in mud under shell fire and sniper
fire day after day is terrible.
While there's plenty of first world war
battles where as a soldier you would
have found yourself in that situation
with bodies all around.
I mean that's not that abnormal in the
first world war.
And they're right about that too.
But you know,
maybe it's fairer to say that there are
several really unbelievably horrible and
unprecedented battles in the first world
war that are equally hellacious.
And you would not want to be at any of
them.
They each have their own awful unique
flavor to them that makes them different
and nothing smells quite like for done.
And if you said to me,
you have to be at one of these horrible
battlefields for Dunn is the lowest on
my list for Dunn is the last place out
of all of them that I want to be.
If you ask what Verdun achieved,
again,
there's a wide variety of opinions on
this.
The most popular is that it achieved
nothing.
One of the broad symbols of the general
wastefulness of this war,
about a million people either are killed
or wounded or you know,
have never returned from that
battlefield and nothing of huge
importance.
It was gained because of that one thing
that certainly did happen as it moved up
the timetable for several other battles
that we're going to happen a little bit
later.
But when the French got pressed by the
Germans have ridden,
they said the British and they send to
the Russians.
You know those battles you were planning
on starting.
Could you move up the timetable and
start them sooner?
We could use the help over here and
finally,
the one thing in 1916 you're beginning
to see,
and we've alluded to this before,
is that these people have put up already
with a lot more pounding than we would
probably put up with today,
but there's a breaking point for all
human beings in my mind.
The breaking point that's coming was
quickened by the experience at Verdun
and we'd mentioned that the French had a
policy of rotating troops during the
battle to keep them fresh at Verdun,
but what that meant was virtually the
entire French army at one time or
another,
was rotated through that sector for
done,
took the French and ratcheted up the
discontent levels in ways that were
probably out of proportion to what you
could have expected from a more normal
battle.
It got you closer to the breaking point.
The idea of pushing your adversary to
the point where their society literally
implodes is a thoroughly modern idea.
By 1916,
most of the military leaders in this
conflict see that as the end game in
this conflict.
The reason it's a thoroughly modern
concept isn't because people of the past
didn't understand it.
It was because they could never take
enough damage to get to that point.
As we've said throughout this series,
nations in the past,
for the most part,
couldn't take a punch.
The ones who could stand out like sore
thumbs.
The Roman republic,
for example,
what makes it so unusual in the military
history sense,
they could sustain defeat after defeat
after defeat and not capitulate.
They could lose a battle of Kony.
They could lose a battle of Lake
[inaudible] in the same war and keep
coming back for more theory.
Unusual.
You know,
a generation before those defeats.
Alexander the great defeats,
the massive and the greatest empire the
world has ever seen.
The Acumen did Persian empire with a
couple of big shots.
There's never enough time for the
society to implode.
A society collapsing at the foundation's
requires that they be able to stand
there and exchange enough punches to get
to that point.
By 1916,
the grinding down of nations as well
underway as author David Fromkin says
the real war had become an economic and
social survival contest,
and the generals are beginning to
organize their strategies to quicken and
hasten this outcome.
For example,
when Falcon high and talks about you
know the idea using attrition
to bleed the French White,
he explains that you don't have to worry
about the Russians anymore because
they're well on their way to having
their entire society collapsed.
He says,
quote,
according to all reports,
the domestic difficulties of the giant
empire are multiplying rapidly.
Even if we cannot perhaps expect a
revolution in the grand style,
we're entitled to believe that Russia is
internal troubles will compel her to get
in within a relatively short period.
In this connection,
it may be taken for granted that she
will not revive her military reputation.
Meanwhile,
we need not be anxious about that.
On the contrary,
it is probable he writes that any such
attempt and the loss is it must involve,
will only hasten the process of
disintegration and quote.
I should also point out that in the 19th
century,
for example,
that kind of disintegration not only
wasn't the goal,
it would have been seen as a negative
byproduct in the era where a military
defeat meant that one general gave his
sword to the other general and we
exchanged some provinces are some
colonies or whatnot.
The goal wasn't for the society to
collapse.
It was now
and military leaders began to employ
strategies designed to make that outcome
a reality.
For example,
when the war starts,
the British used their navy to clamp
down a blockade on Germany.
Now the French don't look at that as a
very useful strategy because after all,
something like that's going to take a
long time and no one win.
This war starts or you know,
a very small minority who turned out to
be Cassandra's and prophetic.
No one thinks the war is going to go
long enough for something like a
blockade to actually take effect.
But by 1916,
everyone is starting to understand that
those longterm anaconda like strangling
strategies are very viable and the
British are not the only ones who can do
this.
After all,
the Germans have a fleet to right,
and this is the point in the story where
it becomes worth talking about again for
a minute.
You see,
this German fleet was a key reason.
The tensions,
especially with Brittany,
increased in the prewar years,
right?
It's called the Anglo German naval
tensions,
but it was considered to be worth it by
a kaiser and a government that thought
it was important to be able to hold your
own at sea.
So these ships were built and they cost
an amazing amount of money.
A huge amount of industrial capacity is
sucked up into this.
As we said,
[inaudible].
You turn up at a basically friendly
Britain into an enemy and now that you
got what you wanted,
it's sitting in port continually and
here you've got your country straining
every fiber you know,
to sacrifice for the war effort.
Heck,
the civilians are starting to cut back
on their caloric intake and here's this
fleet,
so expensive to build and every month
sucking up resources and sitting in
port.
This is the time in the story where
because the Germans get a new admiral,
things start to happen on the surface
naval front for really the only time in
this war.
And if you are our nut for this period
like I am,
I like to call it the battleship era,
somewhere between 1890 ish in 1940 ish
about 50 years.
The era where you get these armored
Lavania fans that are just,
to me,
they're fascinating,
right?
And they're such incredible vehicles
that you may have to fast forward this
show when I start going off on some
detailed tangent that,
you know,
only I find interesting.
Um,
but I,
I think these vehicles are incredible
and there is so little evidence of them
actually being used that on the few
occasions where it happens,
I tend to look at them rather deeply.
There's only one occasion in history.
I don't think I count the Rusa Japanese
war pre dread.
I think only one occasion in history
where these armored ships from this era,
the 50 years battleship era,
actually fought the way these admirals
had envisioned they would in long lines,
miles long lines,
stretching off to the horizon,
you know,
Lord Nelson Style pirates of the
Caribbean style and facing a fleet.
Similarly arrayed and shooting,
you know,
in the distance between them.
That only happened once in this whole 50
year battleship era and only happened
once in this war.
Obviously it's a battle in 1916 called
the battle of Jutland to Kooks like
yours.
Truly.
This is a fantastically interesting
encounter.
When we were thinking about organizing
this story,
you know,
you,
you try to carve out places to take a
little direction,
change in a momentum change.
You know,
you go from the carnage of ridden and
those of you who know the story know
what's coming up in the future of it and
you take a little interlude to talk
about other elements.
Not just the naval side of this,
but also the fact that the navy really
is a wonderful canvas on which to
represent the technology of this era.
And how big of a deal that is to the
people here and that's a perpetual
problem,
isn't it?
Me going back in time and seeing what
looks to be ancient technology to US
looking at it the way the people back
then are looking at it,
to whom it's cutting edge stuff.
I mean,
first of all,
I was trying to think about the best way
to sort of explain,
create an analogy for how these people
see the fleets they have and the fleets
and the navy's along with this new
thing.
These aircraft are the real cutting edge
technology out there.
And the reason why is because it's just
death to be too far behind.
And as I said,
the best navy from 1900 would lose to
several navies from 1914.
That's a mere 14 years.
I don't think those 1914 navy's lose a
ship.
That's how quickly things are changing.
Robert Massey and his book dreadnought
has a great line where he says in 1900,
and that's a mere 14 years before the
first world war breaks out.
Every single British admiral commanding
a British battleship had been trained
when they came up in the navy and the
age of sail.
So that's an example of how cutting edge
this is.
Um,
if you want a mental image,
think of the titanic,
the ship that struck the iceberg and
went down and everything that's from
this era.
It's sort of a steam,
punky Sherlock Holmes.
He kind of feel.
I always think about it as.
I mean if you,
if you are up in the command center,
one of these battleships,
it's like star trek meets Sherlock
Holmes or steam punk and you,
instead of having a digital display,
you'd have one of those in around dials
with one of those arrows that looks like
the elevator Arrow in a nice New York
hotel that goes around on a gold
background.
I mean,
you know,
very,
very beautiful.
Actually.
These ships were beautiful,
polished wood,
the whole thing.
They were just gorgeous and they were
the cutting edge technology of their
day.
And I had to resist comparing them to
space ships as a way to try to have us
feel like the people back then felt.
Because you know me,
that would just be so meta,
so it's just like a star ship,
but it's a little like one but not
enough for the comparison.
Right.
As I thought to myself,
I thought,
you know,
those people saw battleships,
uh,
as,
as really cutting edge,
but not as much as we would spaceships
with an equal number of crew members on
board.
That would be a bigger deal.
But then I remembered the submarines
for the people,
again,
hard for us to get all wild about them,
but to the people back then,
that is science fiction,
the very definition of the word right
out of Jules Verne's,
20,000
leagues under the sea and all of a
sudden we have ships that go underwater.
It's like they have cloaking devices.
They become invisible and worse,
if you're a naval official back then is
that they now carry new weapons that
threatened everything you have.
This is what really accounts for the
cautious nature of naval warfare in this
period,
right?
Why didn't the ships just all come out
blazing and everything while there's all
these uncertainties?
Part of this period's attraction is that
you begin to see a show down in naval
warfare when you haven't had any test of
any of this technology to long time.
No one knows what's going to happen when
you get whole fleets out here blazing
away with this modern technology.
It hasn't happened before.
One of the things everyone's kind of
scared about is you know these torpedoes
for example,
and these minds,
you know these floating minds that that
lay in the water and then a ship runs
into them and boom,
they explode because these weapons are
very,
very cheap,
right?
You can make a lot of them and they can
sync these massively expensive,
you know,
ships that take years to build and who's
lost as catastrophic.
They can sync those.
That's a huge change because in most
naval warfare,
generally there are exceptions,
but when you want to sync a expensive
first class ship,
you generally need either another
massive firstclass ship or a lot of
other ones.
They have huge survival strength,
right?
They,
they can justify their cost and the
investment.
Now all of a sudden,
for example,
Churchill talks about the British
admiralty,
just being petrified that you would turn
around one day and these great,
huge expensive ships that took forever
to build and that you only had a limited
number of were just disappearing in the
blink of an eye boom,
quick explosion,
another ship gone,
and then when the war starts in like the
first couple of months that happens,
they lose a super dreadnought.
The Creme de la creme of the British
battleship forces or the HMS audacious
strikes a mine like,
you know,
a month or two after the war starts and
that's a,
that's a pretty brand new ship almost.
And Boom,
goes down.
One mine,
one battleship.
Wow.
Again,
if you're in the admiralty,
you're going,
okay,
what does this mean?
And then a submarine like sinks,
a couple of old British cruisers,
boom,
boom.
I mean one right after another,
and now all of a sudden you know,
these people who've got these big
expensive ships are petrified about
using them in military history as like
Martin van [inaudible] have spoken about
this.
We just have this strange dichotomy
where you spend so much money on these
vessels because they are very important,
but they,
because you spend so much money on them,
you don't want to reach them.
And so you have the German navy in the
British navy dealing with each other as
maybe two snipers hunting each other
would deal with each other,
waiting for the other side to make a
mistake.
And then when they do pouncing,
the problem is,
is that when the war starts,
the British clamp down that blockade and
that's all they need to do.
The pressures on the Germans to do
something about it.
And as we said,
Winston Churchill,
who was the civilian,
uh,
head of the navy for awhile in this
conflict wrote down that really,
while there would've been a lot of
advantages to sending the,
you know,
numerically superior British fleet to go
in there and just kick German tail.
The downside if you failed to do that
was so bad it wasn't worth it.
He said,
yeah,
you know,
we could get all these good things if we
decisively defeated the German.
But he goes,
but if we lost,
and remember this is all untried
technology and naval combat,
it's weird and unpredictable.
Anyway,
you could bring the superior fleet in
there and somehow lose or just lose
enough so that you don't have the
numerical advantage anymore.
You've got parody with the enemy and
that was unthinkable,
and Churchill said the chances of that
happening might not be great,
but if it happens,
it could cost us the whole war.
I remember reading that and thinking to
myself,
I don't know if I buy it,
but a whole lot of interesting thoughts
come to mind if you believe what
Churchill says about it.
Basically having the potential to end
the war.
Now,
here's how he explained it in his book,
he said,
if the German navy were even to have a
nice victory against the British and cut
down the numerical superiority so that
they both have the same number of big
ships than the German navy would be to
interdict the stuff heading for Britain.
And Churchill says that that would
result in quote,
the trade and food supply of the British
isles would have been paralyzed.
Our armies on the continent would have
been cut off from their base by superior
naval force.
All the transportation of the allies
would have been jeopardized and
hampered.
The United States could not have
intervened in the war.
Starvation and invasion would have
descended upon the British.
People ruin under and final would have
overwhelmed the allied cause.
He says the great disparity of the
results at stake in a battle between the
British and German navy's can never be
excluded from our thoughts.
And so if you buy Churchill's theory,
that means instead of being the most
secure of the great powers that I think
most of us assume Britain is,
after all,
you're talking about an island nation to
country with a moat around it,
right?
And then you add the greatest navy in
the world.
Looks pretty secure to me,
but Churchill's idea here is that,
yeah,
but we're one lucky punch away from that
situation.
Changing to stay with our boxing
analogy,
and if that's true,
the Germans maybe are justified in
keeping that fleet safe and port in case
you need a lucky punch.
Maybe you're losing the war elsewhere
and you decide you'll send your ships on
a death run and take your chances.
Maybe you get lucky,
right?
Maybe you get a knockout blow.
If again,
you buy into what Churchill saying,
it means that the Germans will,
as long as they still have a fleet
somewhere,
maintain the ability to win the war with
a lucky punch at anytime.
I find that fascinating.
Don't know if I believe it,
but find it fascinating.
Now,
the only time in this war that the
attempt at a lucky punch happens.
It wasn't thrown that way,
but the only time that this decisive
encounter that could be potentially
horrifying if it totally went the wrong
way for Britain.
The only time this happens is in this
part of the story.
We're in now,
1916,
and it happens because of that album we
mentioned earlier.
His name is Ryan Hart Shear and he takes
over in early 1916 and he feels about
the German fleet pretty much the same
way everyone else does.
It's time to earn your keep and let's
start acting more aggressively with it.
And so he'll start trying to,
um,
the best way to put it as trap the
British,
the British have more big ships than the
German.
So sheers ideas.
Well,
let's see if we can ambush small numbers
of those big ships,
overwhelmed them and slowly but surely
widdled down the advantage in numbers
that the British have and it's one of
these attempted traps that results in
this really only time for enthusiasts
like yours truly,
to see what these fleets could do in an
all out encounter with both sides,
hurling steel at the horizon and with
all these weapons that,
you know,
from a spectator standpoint,
you're just dying to see what the heck
they can do.
I mean,
let's start with the guns.
The guns on these ships,
the same kind of guns you saw leveling
the Belgian fortune that the Germans
were using it for.
Done.
Those are the big naval guns being used
on land.
Well,
why do you think they call them naval
guns?
Right?
These new battleships,
I mean for example,
the British are bringing in four or five
brand new ones that will fight in the
Second World War Two that have 15 inch
guns and multiple,
I mean like eight to 1215 inch guns.
That's incredible.
13 inches of armor.
They were like 30,000
tons.
The new Queen Elizabeth Class,
they're called.
They can do like 25 knots if they're
really smoking.
These are incredible,
incredible modern warships and when you
realize that they can hurl a shell the
size of a small Volkswagen,
18 miles across the horizon at a target
that's a hundred feet wide while both
shooter and target are moving and hope
to hit it reasonably well.
That's shocking.
I mean the Spanish American war,
uh,
less than 20 years before this time
period,
they would fire hundreds of shots at
about just less than three miles
distance.
And every now and then they'd score a
hit,
you know,
hundreds to get a few in the Russo,
Japanese war,
they broke all records when they opened
fire at each other at eight miles
distance.
That's 11 years before the battle of
Jutland.
Eight miles breaking all records.
The Battle of Jutland has ships that can
fire 18 miles.
How do you even hit anything on the
horizon?
Well,
both sides,
British and German are incorporating,
again,
it's like steam punk technology,
maybe a rudimentary fire control
computer you might call it and both
sides have different versions and the
Germans have superior optics and so
they'll score the early hits in,
in,
in this encounter that happens in large
part because the British are reading the
naval communications of the Germans.
See,
I love the battle of Jutland for a
couple of reasons,
not just because it's the battleship
encounter of the war,
but also because it's a rubber meets the
road moment a put up or shut up
historical acid test where all of the
military theories and the debates and
the,
the philosophical differences amongst
experts over the proper way to build
these ships and what naval battles going
to be like in the next war and all that
stuff leaves the realm of the
theoretical and gets,
you know,
laboratory tested on the naval
battlefield.
The land powers already saw this happen
to them right at the start of the war,
their military land theories and all
that the people had speculated about for
decades,
got their acid test in the first month.
Places like the battles of the frontiers
where those sort of high minded all
academic debates at military war
colleges about whether or not charging
cavalry will have any sort of a role on
the modern battlefield with machine guns
and everything.
I mean that kind of stuff gets tested in
the first month of the war and the
results are of course bloody and
decisive.
Even if they won't be absorbed right
away.
The naval side of this war hasn't had
this kind of an acid test yet.
There've been little encounters,
one of the Falkland Islands and other
one dog or bank between a few cruisers
here in a battle cruiser to there,
but nothing like what's going to happen
at Jutland.
And when you realize how careful these
admirals are being because of the nature
of naval combat,
I mean you could provide an opportunity
for someone to get a lucky punch if
you're not careful.
So none of these admirals wants to go
out,
unless they have an edge,
unless they have an advantage on their
side,
favorable conditions,
it would be called the British don't
have to do anything because they've got
this blockade going.
So worst case scenario,
if things just stay as they are,
they are wearing the Germans down with
this blockade.
They're going to create the
disintegration of a state just like we
told you,
you know,
was the goal.
Now of these leaders,
you know,
if the Germans begin to starve at home
and the caloric intake is already being
reduced for their civilians,
you will see revolution in the streets.
So this British strategy of blockade
will eventually bring Germany to its
knees.
So it's incumbent upon the Germans to do
something about that situation when they
get their new admiral Reinhardt's shear
in 1916 who wants to be more aggressive?
He decides to create his own edge,
you know,
the conditions for his own advantage on
the naval battlefield.
So he sets traps and in late May 1916,
he sets one for what he hopes will be a
detachment of big British warships.
You know,
get five or six battle cruisers and
entice them pastures,
submarines or into your mind fields or
into an area where they think they can
feast on some of your light forces and
then pounce on them with your big fleet
and that's what she plans to do.
And so he sets out all these forces and
prepares this little ambush and what he
doesn't know is that the British,
as we said,
our reading,
all these naval communications,
are the British the greatest
cryptographers on the planet or is that
just the 20th century?
Sort of coloring my view because boy,
were they great in the 20th century,
in the Second World War.
They will famously be reading all the
German enigma traffic among other things
in this war and the first couple of
months the German naval codes fall into
their hands and while they may not be
deciphering every single message when
the entire German high seas fleet as
it's called 100 ships about decides to
way anchor and go out.
You know,
looking to play in the North Sea.
The British know about that.
There'll be big communication spikes and
everything.
So when sheer decides to set this
ambush,
the British reading the naval codes tell
the fleet,
guess what?
The Germans are out there and they don't
know that we know they're out there.
And so the British grand fleet,
thanks.
Okay,
now we have the advantage.
We will trap the trappers.
And so the British Grand Fleet,
which is like 28,
you know,
super dreadnoughts and dreadnoughts.
I mean it's the biggest fleet in the
world.
It's the most powerful fleet in world
history up to this point.
And in terms of size and tonnage,
it may be the biggest fleet ever.
It weighs anchor.
It starts making its way to where this
ambush point is and it leaves so early
by the way,
because it's got all this advanced
information that it totally screws up a
lot of ab role sheers ambush because his
forces,
you know,
he had these submarines that were going
to be outside the British ports and that
they could shoot it.
The British ships,
as they left the harbor,
none of that stuff's ready.
And so the British ships make their way
to the rendezvous point where with the
Germans.
And you're setting up another trafalgar
here.
I mean,
if the British fleet emerges into view
and catches the German fleet there,
you could sink half of it before they
get away.
And then Murphy's law joins the battle.
Murphy's law takes center stage in this
encounter,
by the way,
which would have made a great dress
rehearsal for early 20th century naval
warfare.
Unfortunately,
it's opening night and you know you have
troubles on opening night with all of
the loose ends that haven't been fixed
yet.
Imagine instead of opening night,
you're doing the dress rehearsal and yet
you have 250 ships in about 15 square
miles.
When these things come together,
I mean the things that can go wrong and
do go wrong,
effect this battle mightily.
And it's a good argument for why these
admirals are so cautious.
They know this.
So Murphy's law intervenes while the
British are about to pounce on the
Germans because the British send a
message back to their intelligence
service wanting a confirmation of this
or that.
And the intelligence people reading the
German naval codes tell them that they
made a mistake earlier.
They said,
Oh yeah,
the German fleets not at sea like we
thought there's still safely important,
don't worry about it.
So now these admirals,
who five minutes ago knew where the
German fleet was and we're ready to
pounce on it,
don't know they're there anymore,
but of course they are.
And so now we have both main fleets
close to each other in the North Sea.
None of them aware of the other's
existence.
So the rhythm of this battle of Jutland
is wonderful,
starts off as a trap,
flips into a counter trap,
and now it is serendipitously morphed
into an encounter battle and that's how
it gets started.
German light forces on one side of the
horizon.
British light forces on the other side
of horizon spot,
a civilian trawler between the two of
them.
They can't see each other because
they're so far away.
The curvature of the earth limits their
site,
but they can both see the trawler.
So these light units,
you know,
converge on the trawler to investigate
it,
discovery each other's,
starts shooting and send messages back
to the main fleet saying,
guess what I have found over here on the
other side of the horizon,
the enemy fleet,
right?
And so this creates like a war vortex
where all these naval forces start
converging on this area.
The ships that arrive first are the
battlecruisers.
This is an side of the story because the
battle cruisers are experiencing a test
right now and it's the test of whether
or not the admirals that backed this
entire design in the decades before this
period were correct about it.
This is a theoretical argument until
there's data,
there hasn't been a chance to have any
data.
Now we're going to have data.
Are these ships viable?
Now,
first of all,
you need to know what they are.
A battle cruiser is a hybrid design.
It's supposed to combine the punching
power of a battleship with the speed of
a cruiser.
So if a battleship is like some giant
lion,
for example,
or tiger,
these battle cruisers are more like
panthers.
Now this is going to be confusing
because they are all named after like
giant cats,
and so the flagship of this battle
cruiser squadron on the British side is
the lion.
So don't get confused if I start talking
about the lion.
Um,
but that describes it pretty well.
The hypothetical problem here though,
is that you had to give up to get the
speed of a cruiser.
You had to give up the armor of the
battleship.
So what we have here is a ship with all
the striking power of a battleship,
but one that can't take a punch by a
battleship or its counterparts.
Another battle cruiser.
When this was pointed out before the
war,
the admirals who liked the battle
cruiser concept waved off this worry by
saying don't worry,
speed will be their armor.
And that's where the argument is because
nobody knows if speed will be their
armor.
These battlecruisers approach,
this battle at 26 or 27 knots,
which is amazingly fast for a ship their
size,
there are six of them on the British
side and five of them on the German
side.
And when they meet,
they begin to open fire and only about
like eight miles,
which is short.
And the British have the longer range
guns by the way.
But don't open fire first.
This becomes the first of many things
that the British admiral of these
battlecruisers,
a guy named beatty will be critiqued
about.
You know,
after this battle,
the battle opens up at about 3:45
in the afternoon.
Visually it is hard to see the ships if
you actually see a picture of them at
full tilt are smoking like they're on
fire.
And when you have a bunch of them,
they're putting tons of this dark suit
into the air.
Add to that,
the fact that we're over by Denmark in
the North Sea,
there's fog there,
squalls,
there's missed,
there's rain,
there's all kinds of things that inhibit
the ability to see very well.
And sometimes one fleet will be in a
position where they see the other fleet
really well,
but the other fleet doesn't see them and
vice versa.
So the part of being a good Amaryllis,
trying to arrange your fleet so that the
other fleet is highlighted against the
horizon or in some way makes them an
easier target and your fleet is kind of
obscured and hard to hit,
but ships had not tried to shoot at each
other and some of the ranges they're
going to try to shoot at each other.
Here.
When these battle cruisers start
shooting at about 3:45,
the British shoot long,
initially over the heads of the German
ships,
the German ships are disconcertingly
accurate.
They strike the battle cruiser Tiger
like six times in quick succession with
11 inch shells.
Then at 4:00
they strike the flagship,
the lion with Admiral Beatty on board.
The shells penetrate the Turret,
which is the sort of armored bubble that
that contains the big guns.
The touristy either explodes or catches
on fire and there are photographs,
by the way,
have moments in the battle of Jutland.
They're not great and I always imagine
them zoomed in and colorized,
but you can see the lion burning and it
looks bad and admiral beatty didn't
realize at the time how closely he came
to being blown to kingdom come.
They'll find out later that a guy who
was dying and who had lost both his
legs,
I'm on the lion,
saved the ship by flooding the magazine.
The last order he gave was to to flood
the whole area where the explosives or
to keep them from blowing the ship up.
Now,
if beatty was wondering what it would be
like to see one of these modern amazing
ships explode,
he only had to wait about two minutes.
If you actually look at the moment by
moment rundown of this battle,
and that's part of the fun of naval
battles.
All these ships kept a very descriptive
and detailed logs about their movements
moment by moment by moment.
They've reconstructed this entire battle
from almost each individual ships
viewpoint and the part that strikes you
when you read a rundown is how quickly
everything is happening.
So beatty suffers.
This hit on his own target at like 4:00,
two minutes later,
the HMS indefensible,
a somewhere in the 20,000
tons of battle cruiser explodes,
just explodes in a moment.
It's Churchill in the admiralty is
nightmare come true.
I mean in a blink of an eye,
you have a towering cloud reaching up
like 1500 feet.
Witnesses say you could see,
you know,
funnels and guns and everything shooting
up into the horizon and both sides.
German and British watched this happen
together
out of the more than 1000 sailors on
board the indivisible to survive.
It's hard not to include an account by
one of them.
How do you not include an account of a
survivor of a ship who's magazine gets
penetrated and explodes with him on it?
I guess he was way up high in the top
observational area.
D Still Call that a crows nest.
He said he was 180 feet high.
His name is c Follmer,
and here's how he describes the
explosion of the hms into forgettable.
While he was on board,
there was a terrific explosion aboard
the ship.
The magazines went.
I saw the guns go up in the air just
like matchsticks 12 inch guns.
They were bodies and everything.
She was beginning to settle down within
half a minute.
The ship turned right over and she was
gone.
I was 180 feet up and I was thrown well
clear of the ship.
Otherwise I would have been sucked
under.
I was practically unconscious turning
over really at last.
I came on top of the water.
When I came up,
there was another fellow named Jimmy
Green and we got a piece of wood.
He was on one end and I was on the other
end a couple of minutes afterwards.
Some shells came over and Jim was minus
his head,
so I was left on my lonesome and to
quote now about 20 minutes after that,
the HMS Queen Mary,
another one of these battle cruisers
explodes same way.
I mean a little bit different.
I mean she gets hit and then there's
this pause and sailors are jumping into
the water and then she explodes.
We have accounts from sailors who were
in the water who said that the sky was.
All of a sudden just filled with all
this massively heavy debris that was
falling down on them in the water and
they're all diving under the water
trying to escape giant funnels and big
metal objects falling on them and
probably a lot of them didn't escape.
Again,
more than a thousand of these sailors on
board.
A small handful rescued afterwards,
less than less than 25 and at one point
admiral beatty turns to a subordinate
and says,
there seems to be something wrong with
our bloody ships today.
And he's right.
They're not passing the acid test.
The hypothesis that you know was the
philosophical underpinnings of this
entire class of warships,
at least on the British side,
is proving to be flawed.
They don't have enough armor.
Speed is not turning out to be their
armor and when their armor gets pierced,
you know the way they're handling this
ammunition and the lack of flash
protectors and some other things means
that the magazine is catching on fire
and exploding way too easily and you can
tell that it's happening too easily
because I'm my German side.
It's not happening.
They sacrificed in some other areas,
their guns are smaller,
for example,
they're a little slower in order to a
slab,
some more armor over,
some of these vulnerable points,
and they're not blowing up again.
These Germans build ships like Mercedes
and they're taking a pounding while they
are running away.
Now that's,
that's what you have to notice and
what's happening in these battles.
You know these ships are not stationary,
they're not anchored in staying in the
same spot.
They're all moving and they're all
moving in a specific direction.
The British are chasing the Germans and
the Germans are moving away.
Now,
if you were the British admiral,
this makes perfect sense to you.
You've got the bigger ships,
right?
And until they start exploding around
you,
you have more of them.
Besides that,
you have a bunch of big brand new,
the newest,
most awesome battle ships in the world.
Their Queen Elizabeth Class,
I've already mentioned war spite,
Malaya,
valiant,
and all these famous ships that will all
fight in the second world war.
They are fresh off the docks,
15 inch guns,
30,000
tons,
13 inches of armor and babies got them
with him so you darn right,
these Germans are going to run away.
Nevermind that.
You know,
I tried to communicate with those
battleships using flags.
When you talk about Murphy's law,
interposing,
it's will on this battle.
Part of it has to do with things that
just look so silly.
In hindsight.
You know these ships have radio.
Sometimes these admirals are not that
cool about using it.
Sometimes it has problems by the way,
so sometimes they're blameless,
but a lot of times these animals are
like the old guy trying to use the
computer and there's so much more
comfortable with the way they were
brought up and the things that they did
in the maneuvers in peace time.
And one of the ways these ships
communicate is by running the orders of
the admiral up on a flagpole.
They have all these different flags and
each one means something different.
So when the admiral wants to communicate
to the fleet,
his orders,
they run a flag up the flag pole on his
ship,
the flagship,
and then every other ship is supposed
to,
as they see it,
run up the same one and you get the
message across.
But this is a method that was used a
hundred years before in Lord Nelson's
time when they're fighting Napoleon at
ranges that are exponentially shorter.
Does that make sense?
Exponentially shorter than the distances
in this battle without the smoke and all
these other things.
And in the peace time training,
it seemed to work fine in the rigors of
combat.
It's not working fine.
And the big battleships don't see the
flag change when beatty tells them to do
things.
And um,
they're not here when this battle first
happens,
they've been playing catch up the whole
bottle,
but now you know,
are arriving on the scene and their
shells are falling sort of by the
Germans.
And now the British think they've got
these German battlecruisers pin down.
Even if you know you're losing a few of
your battle cruisers while you chase
them.
But what they don't know is that those
battlecruisers are leading them into the
mall of the entire German navy,
which is coming up from about 40 miles
away,
moving towards them.
What started off as the German trap
flipped into the British counter trap,
evolved and morphed into the encounter
battle has now by almost improvisational
luck,
become a German ambush again,
if successful,
the German fleet could wipe out four or
five battle cruisers and four of the
newest ships in the British navy,
it would be,
I'm sure Winston Churchill would say,
I'm sure I could speak for him here,
a catastrophe and the Germans on the
verge of making it happen,
and then a light cruiser scouting for
the British sees the entire German fleet
on the horizon and radios the message
back to Amarillo beatty and the grand
fleet under Admiral Jellicoe farther
away and beatty sees those Germans very
quickly too with the naked eye.
The first thing he does when he realizes
he's been baited into this trap is turn
his battle cruisers a hundred and 80
degrees in the other direction and start
booking out of there.
Once again,
Murphy's law,
I'll say that many times in this battle
if I go too deeply into it,
um,
once again he runs up the flag saying
turnaround and the big battleships,
the brand new ones don't see it and they
will end up exposed out there to the
entire German fleet for a while taking a
pounding and dishing one out too.
It should be pointed out nonetheless,
what Admiral Beatty has done by turning
180 degrees away,
his turn himself into bait and the
Germans are following and beatty is
running back towards his big fleet,
which is coming up from also about 40
miles away.
So now he's flipped the ambush once
again and now the Germans are heading
toward the only fleet that is still
invisible on this naval battlefield to
anyone.
The Germans don't know that the British
grand fleet is up ahead of them,
but now the British Grand Fleet knows
that the Germans are coming.
An Admiral Jellicoe in a,
in a very brave move.
I mean he's operating without enough
information.
Once again,
admiral beatty gets blamed for not given
him,
you know,
good positional information or whatnot,
but a lot of this falls into the
category of.
It's a dress rehearsal to these guys.
A lot of their errors are the kinds of
things they would have corrected if
they'd had a chance to practice it in,
you know,
combat situations.
Unfortunately these are a lot of,
you know,
you wouldn't call them rookie mistakes,
but.
But you would correct these before the
next battle.
Nonetheless,
jellicoe takes a chance,
deploys the entire British grand fleet,
which is more than 100,
ships over 15,
20 square miles of ocean.
It takes 15 to 20 minutes.
That's how well trained this fleet is.
And he deploys the whole thing and he's
waiting for the Germans to arrive and
the Germans are now in the midst,
right?
This battlefields,
very misty and you'll,
you'll run through fog banks and you
won't see things for awhile and the
Germans can't see what's going on.
And famously Amro hipper,
who's the German admiral in charge of
the battlecruisers radios,
Admiral Shear the head of the entire
German navy,
who's with the German fleet here,
and he famously looks off into the mist
and tell sheer something lurks in that
soup.
We would do well not to thrust into it
too deeply,
too late.
The first thing that happens is,
is the German start taking some fire and
they don't know from where big guns.
And then all of a sudden the missed
parts for a.
and
it's a nother British battlecruisers the
invincible.
And as soon as the mist parts in the
invincible becomes clear,
you know,
it doesn't take 90 seconds before big
German guns are opening fire,
the shells pouring down on the
invincible.
And like the other two battle cruisers,
the invincible explodes.
So if anybody has forgotten in the
intervening,
you know,
hour or two,
since the earlier battlecruisers
exploded,
that this design is proving to be
somewhat flawed.
The explosion of the invincible before
the two main fleets collide is a
historical reminder.
Nonetheless.
It's only soon after that that the
Germans emerge from the mist to find the
entire deployed British fleet waiting
for them in like a crescent around the
horizon and sheer says the minute that
they can see what's happening,
the entire horizon erupts in a sheet of
flame.
Now these ships are a long way from each
other,
almost invisible to the naked eye,
smudges up against the horizon.
You see like the smoke of all the ships
and then you see like the flash of the
guns and just like lightening and
thunder where you see the lightening and
then there's this delay and then the
thunder arrives.
Same thing.
You see this flash and it's silent and
then boom,
the boom hits you after the shells have
already passed over and you know there
are destroyers in these battles.
We haven't even talked about all the
lights.
Ships running around,
you know,
sort of parrying and like,
like a bunch of little gnats between the
battle fleet and these destroyers
sometimes describe what it's like when
these giant shells pass over their heads
and they say they sound like locomotives
when they screech over your little ships
head,
but when they fall in front of your
little ship,
you're like your little destroyer.
They raise geysers of water,
sometimes 100,
sometimes 200 feet up into the air and
it's composed of tons of liquid,
which then falls back down to earth.
And these destroyers,
these little ships are sometimes beaten
up pretty severely by all this water
smashing back down into them.
Some people are splashed overboard and
all these kinds of things.
Nonetheless,
Admiral Jellicoe has performed a famous
naval maneuver that you never want to be
on the receiving end of called crossing
the t where he's formed the top crossbar
of the t and poor shear.
And the Germans form the,
um,
you know,
vertical line of the t and every one of
the British ships can fire on the German
ships individually as they come to the
front of the line.
It's a disaster very quickly.
Sheer gets hit with more than 22 heavy
shells fast.
And within 10 minutes shear has quite
tactically adroitly by the way,
turned his fleet around and disappeared
back into the mist and once again
without radar and all that kind of
stuff,
uh,
hard to,
you know,
know where he is at that point and he
sends out a bunch of light units and
destroyers and what not to cover his
escape.
So the,
the British can't just after them,
they might
run into a bunch of torpedoes and mines
and stuff.
And then inexplicably,
not too long after the sheer arrives
back into visual range and you know,
people fire again and then sheer escapes
again because he got his t crossed for a
second time in one battle,
which is almost unheard of.
It shows you jellicoe is pretty darn
good admiral.
And then there's a little night action
between the light units,
but about this time admiral shares had
enough.
You get your tea cross twice in one day.
It's time to call it a battle.
And Shear in the Germans manage to limp
home
when all is said and done.
The British lose three battlecruisers,
three armored cruisers and destroyers,
while one German battle cruiser,
one pre dreadnought battleships for
light cruisers and destroyers are sent
to the bottom.
The casualties at Jutland are not
significant.
They don't hurt either navy badly.
Uh,
the British learned their lesson about
the battle cruiser design,
but the Germans are humbled,
you know,
they don't come out again in strength.
I mean there's,
there'll be a little encounter here and
a little try there.
But,
but this is it.
They gave it an attempt and they seemed
permanently shaken because of it.
The German surface fleet will not
perform another militarily significant
move in the war.
The only part of the German navy that's
going to be relevant for the rest of the
war is the part that uses torpedoes to
go after.
Not military targets,
but economic ones.
By 1916,
the economic side of this war is coming
to the fore.
We begin to see what war on this scale
is like when it becomes part of the
normal life of all of these countries.
Do you know this isn't a new phenomenon
anymore?
By 1916,
by the middle of 1916,
we've been doing this for two years and
it's been sucking up more and more of
the energy of these nation states that
are involved in the conflict.
It's very unlike the way most wars by
these powers had been fought where the
civilian population might not even know
a war is happening if it was happening,
they certainly weren't directly or
importantly impacted.
This war is different.
First of all,
it's life or death.
The stakes are so high that everybody's
involved and the armies are requiring
such immense amounts of stuff.
You know,
the Germans will call this material
schlock the war of material that the
entire civilian population and the
production capacity of all these
countries gets warped.
Trying to provide it.
As historian Gwynne Dyer says,
quote,
it is significant that the phrase
homefront
came into use during World War One when
the role of munitions workers,
enough civilian production more
generally was becoming as important to
victory as the soldiers in the trenches
without a constant flow of supplies
equal to the vast consumption at the
front.
The soldiers would soon be helpless,
and since the mobilization of so huge,
a number of men left vast gaps in the
normal workforce,
France had put 20 percent of its entire
population into uniform,
Germany,
18 percent and the other major powers,
not much less.
The remaining adult civilians had to be
directed by government into whatever
jobs were needed to keep production
going.
In effect,
the civilian economy he writes,
was conscripted to the governments of
Europe quickly took control over labor
and raw materials,
imposed rationing,
scarce goods,
and created true war economies.
Women flooded into factories to replace
the men at the front and most production
beyond the basic needs of subsistence
was diverted into the war effort and
quote,
diyers,
also the one that said,
by this time,
quote,
battles had become an industrial
operation in reverse.
In which the rates of destruction at the
front matched the rates of production in
the industry's at home.
And to quote,
I think of guys like the British
military leader,
Hey meg,
or even the German military leader
General Eric Von Falcon Han and I think
about all these skills that they're
required to have now above and beyond
what you would think of as a normal
generals skills.
And you saw this in earlier wars.
There's famous stories of General
Sherman in the civil war in the United
States being extra qualified for modern
warfare because of all these failed jobs
in private industry.
He'd had the taught him all these
lessons that no one knew at general
would need in modern warfare.
Things about logistics and stuff like
that.
But by 1916,
you a guy like,
hey,
a cavalry commander.
It looks like he would be totally out of
his element,
uh,
dealing with the modern production needs
of warfare as indeed he was Falcon
Hines,
a bit more scientific of a guy.
And he's,
you know,
I was trying to think if I were general
fall behind,
if this were a war game.
And,
you know,
I played a lot of those in my time and
I,
and I got a signed because I don't think
I would take Germany,
uh,
if I had a choice of which side of the
war game I wanted to play,
but let's say I get assigned to Germany
and I command and played Germany in this
war game and I'm Falcon,
you know,
the estimates are,
especially during this time period that
if you include the colonial subjects of
the,
of the powers in Europe during this time
period,
my enemies in this war,
if I'm falling behind and have $750
million people they can call on for
their value in their effort.
And in some cases their lives.
My side of the alliance has about $150
million.
My enemies have the greatest fleet in
the world.
And I just learned at the battle of
Jutland that my navy can't come anywhere
near touching them
and they've shut down all of my overseas
trade.
So if I'm General Falcon High and
already I'm sitting here going,
wow,
now you look at the lineup in terms of
the kinds of countries in each alliance,
right?
You have the British and the French and
the Russians as the three big guys in
the allied Entente alliance.
These are all first rate powers.
Betsy power,
best land power,
biggest power,
all three together.
Wow.
And then they have a bunch of other
countries like Italy and smaller powers.
That's a very powerful force.
Who Do I have on my side?
Austria,
Hungary,
Bulgaria and Turkey.
Basically,
none of those powers are first rate.
At least the Turks aren't asking me for
help all the time.
If I'm Falcon nine though,
they're putting on a pretty brave fight.
They've managed to kick the British,
French,
South Africans,
Indians,
New Zealanders and Australians out of
Gullapalli in January,
1916.
That's unexpected.
They've managed to beat the British
forces,
mostly Indian troops in a place called
coot and modern day Iraq trap them in a
fortress.
They're forced them to surrender and
took them on a death march,
but it really doesn't impact Falcon hind
very much.
One way or the other,
it's just nice for him to know that the
Turks are winning as opposed to losing
because they are losing against the
Russians,
but it's a mixed bag.
Remember,
the Turks are tough,
but they are not quite a 20th century
army,
so those are all that's gravy to Falcon
Hein.
The bigger problem,
if you're [inaudible] hine is your,
your close allies,
the Austro-hungarian,
they're a pain in the rear.
They don't listen to you to begin with.
You're having fights with their main
military leaders and then they go do
what they want anyway and then they
screw up because they didn't follow your
advice and then they come to you and
say,
will you bail us out?
If you're falling behind?
They're a pain in the rear and he's
continually having to take scarce troop
from places like Verdun and instead
taking the train,
sending them over east and and saving
the Hungarians Bacon.
Can't really blame them though.
They're in big trouble anyway.
They may not have been a country in
1920,
even if there hadn't been a first world
war.
They're made up of 11 major ethnic
groups in that state,
some of whom don't want to be there,
and their army is a microcosm of their
state and you've got troops who don't
even want to be in your empire at times
on the front line that you're asking to
die for your empire.
It's not a good situation.
They're constantly getting into trouble
and as one German diplomat famously says
about Germany's situation with Austria
hungry,
we are fettered to a corpse were tied to
a dead guy,
and that's the Austro-hungarian forced.
Now in your favor,
if you're Falcon Hine,
you probably have the best army in the
world.
The 1916
German army is fantastic.
It's a combination of the best aspects
of the 1914 force that Germany went to
war with,
but battle hardened by experience.
Here's the way writer in Passingham
describes it,
quote,
it is true that the German army on the
western front by early 1916,
was more skilled and better equipped for
trench warfare.
The neither the British or the French.
This is not too surprising.
He says,
as the British expeditionary force,
it only just expanded its army from
around 250,000
in 1914 to just over a million,
largely inexperienced men and the French
he writes,
had always been uncomfortable with the
notion of defensive operations rather
than the offensive spirit.
He then says,
quote,
many of the German veterans of the
inconclusive,
though bitter fighting at IPA,
Chappelle artois champagne and loose in
1915 had survived and stiffened,
didn't army that had been well led at
the sharp end and remained resolute
against allied efforts in the West.
It had come close to beating the Russian
armies on the eastern front in that
year.
Also,
in short,
as John Terrain has noted,
it must never be forgotten that the
German army of that period was very good
indeed and quote.
So that's what you bring to the table.
Is that enough?
Is having the best army in the world
enough.
And by the way,
that's something you traditionally think
of when you think of the French,
but it's safe to say,
I think that since about 18,
70,
the Germans have the best army in the
world.
Will that compensate for all the
downsides of the central powers?
Have hard to know.
One of the worst is the fact that the
left hand and the right hand don't know
what each other are doing in the central
powers.
The Austrians go off the reservation all
the time.
Don't tell anybody what they're doing,
don't get any approval,
don't work together with anyone,
and it's a handicap,
especially when the allies slash entente
forces are pretty darn good at this.
They have an agreement that they made in
1915 to come to the aid of each other
when hard pressed,
when the Germans launch for done within
a month,
the Russians come riding to the rescue
in Lithuania trying to help they launch
an offensive that they are clearly not
ready for and how could you be?
That would be a very short time in this
period to have planned and stocked up
for and carried out an offensive.
In March 19,
16,
the Russians throw human wave attacks at
the Germans and predictably get mowed
down.
The Germans,
you know,
looking at the corpses,
thought these people totally untrained
cannon fodder as though the Russians
were willing to throw tons of human meat
at the Germans simply to scare them
enough so that they would pull some
units out of redundant,
takes some pressure off the French.
It was so inept that some of the
casualties the Russian soldiers suffered
were because of being shelled by their
own sides.
Artillery,
which is always a tragedy,
and 12,000
Russian soldiers froze in one night.
A lot of these were wounded,
bought a bunch,
were people that just,
you know,
we're out there in the cold without the
proper stuff.
I mean the Russian logistics are
traditionally pretty horrible,
especially in this period.
It shows you the nature of operations
there.
The Russians are not generally thought
of is handling these sorts of things.
Well and in March 1916,
they don't handle it well.
Again,
the worst part probably from the Russian
perspective though,
is they went to all that trouble and it
didn't take any pressure off the French
at Verdun.
The follow up effort though,
by the Russians on June fourth,
1916 will be handled much better,
surprisingly well.
If you're a guy like Falcon Hein and
you've written off with a lot of your
other generals,
any chance the Russians have of doing
anything significant in 1916 on June
fourth,
1916,
the Russians do something very
significant lead by their unquestionably
best general in the first world war.
A guy named Bruce Hill off.
We had mentioned in an earlier episode
that the Russians simply couldn't
attack.
I mean they were.
They were okay sometimes on the defense,
but they couldn't attack on.
The problem is always the same.
They just have such an old fashioned,
not up to date logistic system that the
farther you moved away from where you
started,
the harder it was to get the supplies
necessary for modern army to run.
But Brasil of is the most modern
commander the Russians have.
He's been learning from fighting the
best army in the world.
The Germans all this time,
and even though he's a cavalry commander
and they have a reputation for always
being sort of old fashioned Bursa love,
embraces the new systems out there in
the new technology.
For example,
he does something almost no Russian army
ever does in the first world war.
He uses aircraft to help as spotters and
to locate positions behind the lines and
for reconnaissance right there,
he's acting in a much more modern way
than Russian armies do.
Remember we're talking about an army
that for the entire length of the first
world war will still be wearing cloth
cap.
They never get metal helmets during the
duration of the first world war.
So this is a very old fresh fashioned
army law of takes.
What he can do that's modern and uses
it.
He launches his famous offensive named
after him on June fourth,
and he does so with a very modern
artillery barrage intense but short.
He's used all sorts of camouflage to
hide his intentions.
He went as far as painting fake trenches
on the ground behind his lines to
confuse the Germans and the
Austro-hungarian is on the other side.
And when he launches his attack,
he does so along an enormous front,
the eastern front,
very different than the western front,
and instead of being this really
constrained small area which they can
build a wall from side to side real
easily,
it's a huge area,
so it's much more thinly defendant.
And what [inaudible] does is he attacks
across this giant front with a half
million men intending to break upon the
defenses of the central powers,
like a way of breaks on a breakwater.
And knowing that in many places his
forces will get pushed backwards.
But where he meets weakness,
they should burst through.
Here's the way writer Gj Meyer explains
what happens on June fifth,
within hours after the artillery
bombardments starts,
they have million Russian forces step
out of their trenches and moved toward
the mostly Austro-hungarian lines,
but they're a German troops.
To quote his infantry when it attacked
on June fifth,
found the Austrians and confusion.
It's advanced,
stunned them with its scope extending as
it did along the line of more than 250
miles still loves.
The idea was that by attacking
everywhere,
he was sure to find holes somewhere and
he had moved his reserves,
scant,
though they were close enough to the
front so that they could exploit
opportunities as soon as any appeared,
and he continues quote,
and the result was from the first hour a
success of almost incredible magnitude.
The Austro-hungarian Fourth Army
disintegrated when hit 71,000
of its men.
More than half the army were killed,
wounded or captured.
The seventh was wrecked even more
completely losing 133,000
men.
It was the same almost everywhere.
After three days,
bruce,
he found himself in possession of
300,000
prisoners before the end of the week.
More than half of the Austrian defenders
had become casualties and quote Brasil
have shattered the Austrians,
and then he ran into the typical
problem.
Any Russian commander runs into the
inability of the Russian army in
government to get him enough stuff fast
enough for him to not slow down and have
his offensive Peter out.
But this maneuver had a domino effect on
the war because at Verdun Falcon Hein
now had a crisis on his hands in the
east where he was going to have to pull
troops out of Verdun to go save the
Austro-hungarian army,
which was disintegrating.
And let's understand the
Austro-hungarian forces we told you
about those,
those troops who were a microcosm of the
empire as a whole who didn't want to be
there.
You had whole units and I mean
battalions,
regiments of slobs throw down their
weapons and surrender to the Russians,
who by the way are Slavs to let us not
forget that this war began when a slavic
national assassinated austro-hungarian
heir to the throne,
right?
And now we're asking slavs to fight for
that empire.
Many of them threw down their weapons.
They didn't want to die,
and they certainly do more die fighting
for that empire,
and they certainly didn't want to die
fighting for that empire against their
Slavic brethren.
In fact,
some of these units are said to have
jumped into the trenches with the
Russians,
turned around and trained their guns
back on the side.
They had just defected from the Germans,
will manage to contain with their
wonderful army,
the Russian threat,
and they will halt mercy,
loves advance,
and even deal a defeat to the Russians,
but already the single minded focus of
falcon heights on Verdun has been
shattered.
The Russians who put in such a wonderful
effort in the brewster love offensive
and did such terrible damage to the
Austrians suffered immensely though
while doing so well over a million
casualties suffered in the brewery love
offensive,
which once again takes the Russians and
begins to ratchet up the level of
dissatisfaction,
getting them closer and closer to the
breaking point.
You can almost feel it in the air.
In 1916,
a couple of these major powers are
within one good punch of going down in
the spring of 1916.
French military leader,
Joseph you offer,
tells his British counterpart that
France is one of those nations
within a good shot of going down.
Remember,
you know by this time they've had a
month or two at Verdun.
The French have suffered like 200,000
casualties and at least this early two
months into 10,
but nobody knows it yet.
At the battle of redundant looks like
the German leader,
Falcon Heinz plan to bleed.
The French army white is working.
That's why you can't take your eyes off
the first world war.
They're like two prize fighters and just
when you think one guy's taken over the
fight,
the other guidelines,
a good shot and somebodies knees buckle,
and in the spring of Nineteen 16,
Jennifer tells Sir Douglas Haig,
the current commander of British forces,
it's France whose knees had been buckled
and he urges Hague to start that summer
offensive that he's been planning for a
long time on the river somme early.
He says,
if you don't start it early,
the French army will cease to exist.
He gets so worked up.
We're told that he can only be consoled
and calmed down with lots of 1840
brandy,
you know,
from the year 18,
40 chauffeur needed good brandy to calm
down.
Nonetheless,
Haig speeds up the big offensive plan
for the summer of 1916.
Discussed with all the other allies in
late 1915,
this is a longterm plan and the going
gonna launch it early.
This longterm plan results in the most
controversial piece from the British
standpoint of this whole war,
maybe of British military history in its
entirety.
First of all,
Douglas Haig,
you have to understand that the field
marshal the Java was talking to is the
new guy.
Just like most of the great powers in
the first world war.
By 1916,
they fired the person that got them into
this mess,
right?
The wars terrible.
Everybody's predictions were wrong.
Nobody's fighting it well,
so one by one,
all of these countries are sac in the
people that got them into this mess,
the Russians dropped.
There's the Germans have falcon heights
because they got rid of unmold killed
while the war was,
you know,
in its early phases,
the French still have shopped for a
crazily enough.
But um,
you know,
that reputation of the miracle of the
and in 1914 will only carry you so far.
He doesn't have long to go either and
the British in late 1950 and Sir John
French,
like we told you in the last episode,
the guy who gets his gig is a guy named
Douglas Haig.
It'll be a field marshal.
He's another one of these cavalry
commanders.
So it was weird.
We have a war where cavalry becomes
something that you keep off to the side
and don't use because it just gets
killed and the horses are more important
to move stuff because crazily enough,
and we haven't talked enough about this
and we'll get to it.
Horses are everywhere.
There's millions of them in this war and
their casualties too,
by the way,
but all these cavalry commanders,
French,
hey golf,
these guys have these visions that we're
going to break the German lines
somewhere and then the cavalry is going
to go rushing in the hole we create and
go into the back.
And it's,
it's the pre,
you know,
Wehrmacht Armor,
Blitzkrieg version of that.
That's a strategy that's been used
throughout history,
right?
Um,
goes back to pre Alexander time,
smashed the cavalry into the hole and
roll up the lines.
It's blitzkrieg before you have motor
vehicles,
and that's what these cavalry commanders
are still dreaming of two years into the
war that puts the final nail into the
coffin,
into the idea that this cavalry has any
offensive role to play.
Although you have to remember,
it still is the fastest moving thing on
the battlefield.
In large numbers,
you're starting to get motor vehicles,
but you know,
tough for the motor vehicles to handle
terrain and they're very unreliable.
Horses are still the fastest mobility
you have,
so they're valuable just for that point
alone.
They're very vulnerable though.
And the stories of,
of,
of dead horses in the suffering of
animals in the story is under discussed.
Nonetheless.
Douglas Haig,
the new British cavalry commander,
um,
has at his disposal some of the largest
really the largest armies that Britain
has ever had ready to go to war because
those volunteers that started joining
when Lord Horacio Kitchener,
you'll remember the British military
leader from the beginning of the war.
The guy who,
when you see his picture,
screams,
19th century man on it.
I mean,
you know,
with the giant mustache from another
area,
you can almost see him in a British red
coat and he's the big face on the
recruiting poster telling Britain's
patriotic Britain's to sign up for king
and country and a shilling and kitchen
is another one of these prewar early war
generals and military leaders who's been
tarred by,
you know,
their conduct in the war.
They don't,
they don't end up looking so genius like
when the first world war gets done with
you,
right.
So as kitchener,
his reputation is starting to wane.
He still got one real feather in his cap
and that's that those armies that he
helped recruit in 1914 in 1915 and that
he is protected like a proud parent,
you know,
don't send them to Gullapalli.
Don't send him to the western front
early.
Don't throw them in the meat grinder
like everything else,
save them and really make use of their
patriotic contribution.
These people want to win the war,
let's put them in a position where they
can do that.
He's done an admirable job of that in
about three weeks before those soldiers
known sometimes as the kitchen or armies
or the kitchen or divisions after him
are going to lose the guy that was
probably most responsible for seeing
that they weren't used up already in the
first place.
Kitchener dies about three weeks before
his legions are thrown into the frame.
It's a crazy story.
I'm told that it is the same as any one
of those big modern deaths,
so so the same as a princess or lady
Diana dying or Winston Churchill dying
or JFK dying in the United States.
You say to yourself,
do you remember when that happened?
And Britain's of the period,
remember where they were when they heard
that Lord Horacio Kitchen.
They're British military leader and
almost Demi God,
at least at the beginning of the war,
has gone down at sea while on a war ship
on the way to Russia on some military
mission and the boat goes down at night
in a force nine gail after hitting a
mine,
and there are survivors who say,
take this with a grain of salt that they
saw kitchener on the deck as the ship
went down in passively sort of accepting
his fate and just standing on the deck
as the ship goes,
you know,
beneath the waves that really works with
that whole 19th century military leader
reputation,
doesn't it?
Nonetheless,
there have been conspiracy theories ever
since about this.
Believe it or not,
it's one of the Great Conspiracy Know
Fountain heads to come out of the first
world war.
Nonetheless,
it meant the three weeks later when
kitchener's,
you know,
parentally preserved armies are finally
thrown into the fray.
He's not there to have any say in it.
The Guy who is is Douglas Haig,
the new guy now known to some in history
as the butcher.
So that should give you an idea of what
we're about to get into here on a wide
variety of fronts.
This battle is won that Sir Douglas Haig
has been preparing for since the year
before when the French told him that
they were in danger of disintegrating.
He's moving up something he's been
working on for awhile now and everyone
knows it.
The big 1916 offensive is no secret.
Hekaton newspapers basically means that
when you find out all the ways that
everybody knew this was coming,
it makes you wonder again how
intelligent it is to be launching
something that everybody knows is
coming,
but it couldn't really be helped.
If you're going to fight at this spot on
the Somme River with the British and the
French forces meet on the western front
where the where the British line ends
and the French line begins,
that's where they're going to hold this
joint offensive.
Maybe for the sole reason that that's
where both armies are.
That would be a really silly reason to
attack the greatest defenses on the
western front,
which are the greatest defenses ever in
the world right now.
These are defenses that make the old
Roman,
um,
you know,
lines that you would cross Europe with
these giant wall miner.
It has never been defensive like this.
The Germans are at the point now where
they're building creature comforts into
their fortified line.
I mean,
they're putting wallpaper on and they've
got electric lights and ventilation and
then no running water.
I mean it's crazy though.
The trenches or in some cases all lined
with wood boards done with about as much
thorough on this as the Germans are
known for.
These are huge modern fortifications in
some sense.
And these Germans on the other side of
this line where the French and the
British are thinking about launching
this big 1916 offensive have bunkers
that are 30 and 40 feet underground,
cut into the chalk of these hills that
the Germans occupied.
They are looking down for months as the
British load up.
All the stuff you now need for a modern
offensive.
All that stuff.
We said that the German's needed at
Verdun,
the British need at the Somme,
right?
The French too,
by the way.
They've laid five railroad lines,
you know,
new tracks to the battlefield because
that's how often and how many trains are
going to be running,
just unloading stuff for months,
$3,
million shells,
millions of tons of food.
I mean crazy in engineering corps that
are building things,
you know,
full on permanent structures.
While the Germans watched the whole
thing and plan for it and trained for
it,
they're having drills every day.
You know,
how quickly can we get up from our
underground bunker and get up to the
trench and man the machine guns before
the British soldiers are on top of us,
right?
Everybody knows this is coming and
everybody knows how it's going to be
fought.
The British take these armies with many,
many,
many green troops that had never been in
a battle,
puts them in the trenches opposite these
German lines.
Again,
a position so strong that Winston
Churchill says it was undoubtedly the
strongest and most perfectly defended
position in the world and the quote,
and start bombarding it with artillery
starts June 20,
fourth,
19,
16,
early.
By the way,
a lot of artillery.
As a matter of fact,
the song becomes one of about four or
five first world war battles that
compete for like the Guinness Book of
World Records for the biggest,
largest,
worst,
more intense,
most numerous,
you know,
pick your category,
artillery bombardment of the war
there.
You know,
as a history geek,
I would be arguing it with my other
history geek friends.
And,
and it's always about criteria,
right?
Are we talking about the largest number
of shells fall throughout an entire
battle,
you know,
40 to 60 million of verdun maybe.
Or are we talking about the most number
of shells used in the initial part of
the battle or the most number of shells
dropped in the shortest period of time
or the smallest space.
I mean,
there's literally a measurement of how
many tons of shells fell on each square
meter of these battlefields.
And by the way,
if you use that as your criterion for
Dunn is the worst artillery bombardment,
um,
in history.
Nonetheless,
the fact that the psalm is in this
argument shows you the level of
artillery we're talking about here.
And when it opens up on the 24th,
it's,
it's incredible and it's volume,
but the Germans laugh a little.
I mean it's a huge bombardment,
but the Germans are mostly underground
and under cover and most of the
bombardment is,
once again,
shrapnel shells,
sounds like a little teeny point,
doesn't it for a battle to turn on,
but had those shells been high explosive
instead,
or maybe even gas,
this battle may go another direction and
every historian brings up that the
shrapnel was pretty much pointless.
It's remember it's like a giant hand
grenade or shotgun shell exploding in
the air and all these little pellets hit
the ground.
It's devastating to infantry out in the
open,
but the Germans aren't in the open,
right?
In addition,
the artillery is meant to do more than
just killed Germans.
The artillery has to clear the
battlefield of all this stuff that's
there as defenses so that the troops on
the British side can actually get to the
German trenches.
It's full of barbed wire.
No Man's land,
another trench than another no man's
land than another trench.
The trenches are all going uphill and
these no man's land areas besides being
filled with concrete bunkers and
everything we've told you about before,
the killing zones,
they have yards of barbed wires thick as
your finger.
It's a physical impediment.
It has to be overcome by the generals.
The generals have figured out in their
minds that an artillery barrage of this
caliber,
the amounts we're talking about here,
the barb wire will just explode into
pieces.
They will not be an impediment when the
artillery barrages over,
except the shrapnel shells,
don't really affect it.
Now,
there was a benefit to the artillery
barrage,
though as we've quoted before,
Napoleon has this great line that comes
in handy all the time.
That quantity has a quality all its own
and the sheer intensity of this barrage
began to have an effect on the Germans,
even though they were physically
protected from being injured by it.
It began to play on them.
First of all,
they know they've got something really
nasty awaiting them in their future.
You have to try to put yourself in their
shoes.
Okay?
They know that when this artillery
barrages over the British are going to
be on them.
They've been training for this moment
for months,
right?
Run up the stairs.
How quickly can you get in front of the
machine,
gun in time to stop the British from
taking over your trench so they're going
to either be killed,
bee grievously wounded,
see a friend killed or wounded or have
to kill some of them.
They're going to have a really nasty day
and they're very near future.
In the meantime,
you're going to have one of the greatest
artillery barrages and history going on
around you or younger who will be at
this battlefield in about a month and
see a an artillery barrage that is not
as bad as this one.
He will compare it to the roar of the
ocean.
He will say that there are no individual
sounds and he says he will.
It will achieve at times and last for
hours.
A demented intensity that he says when
it eventually calms down,
calms down to mere drum fire,
which is,
you know the sound of a drum roll.
That's how fast the artillery shells are
dropping,
and he says,
even when it's the drum roll,
you can't pick out any individual
explosions.
It's just one big loud sound,
but the demented theory that it reaches
sometimes blows that away literally.
And that's the kind of intensity these
soldiers are living with,
knowing that they've got this horrible
moment in their future and it goes on
for days and we're told that the German
soldiers who were kind of laughing at
the fact that the British were using
like 70 percent shrapnel shells on them
aren't laughing anymore.
They're getting tired and stressed and
you know,
put yourself in the position of just not
sleeping for five days and now,
you know,
add all the other things on top of that.
So there is an effect that this
artillery is having.
And the Germans all right about it.
Um,
the British commander,
this is part of the controversy.
We're told that there were lots of
people saying that this artillery
barrage was going to make this a cake
walk.
And you've heard that before,
right?
Don't all these battles between to sound
like isn't there a repetitiveness to the
story?
If there is,
you're getting the right feeling out of
it because that's how you know it's
always been played and it seems like the
people at the time felt too.
Oh No,
not again,
haven't we seen this movie before?
The general seem to always just want
more stuff.
Give us more artillery,
give us more men,
give us deeper defensive,
you know,
we'll fix this situation.
So here's the biggest artillery barrage.
The British I've ever launched.
They shoot off 2 million shells in no
time.
And just for comparison purposes,
100 years before this time,
at the battle of waterloo,
Napoleon is estimated to have had about
20,000
Canon balls with the French army.
So you know,
2 million shells in a week or two versus
20,000.
It's,
it's crazy.
The level of artillery we're going to
see here and it,
it lowers the commander's into this
sense that it's going to accomplish so
much more than it does.
It's the soldiers on the ground though
that produced the historical reminders
that most of them were too realistic and
to savvy and too cynical to buy into any
of that.
Rosie thinking that generals could
afford to be rosy.
The guys on the ground going in,
for example,
the first wave of this assault that the
Germans had been waiting for you for
months.
They know better and you can tell
because there are absolutely
heartbreaking.
Last letters home that have made it into
the history books.
Peter Hearts,
wonderful book on the Great War,
um,
has one of these letters from a captain
Charles May who fights in the 22nd
Manchester Regiment and he's writing to
his wife right before he goes over the
top in this battle.
And,
and,
and again,
imagine,
imagine how it affects you to be in the
position of writing a letter like this.
I always think that that's,
that's a permanent scar on your soul.
Even if you get the proverbial reprieve
from the governor,
right from Captain Charles may have the
22nd Manchester Regiment who's about to
go over the top on the first day of the
somme.
And writes his wife,
quote,
I must not allow myself to dwell on the
personal.
There is no room for it.
Here also,
it is demoralizing,
but I do not want to die.
Not that I mind for myself.
If it'd be that I am to go,
I'm ready,
but the thought that I may never see you
or are darling baby again,
it turns my bowels to water.
I cannot think of it with even the
semblance of equanimity.
My one constellation is the happiness
that's been ours.
Also,
my conscience is clear that I've always
tried to make life a joy to you.
I know at least that if I go you will
not want that is something,
but it is the thought that we may be cut
off from one another which is so
terrible and that our baby may grow up
without my knowing her and without her
knowing me.
It's difficult to face and I know your
life without me would be a double blank,
yet you must never let it become holy.
So for to you will be left the greatest
charge and all the world,
the upbringing of our baby.
God blessed that child.
She's the hope of life to me,
my darling are of law.
It may be that you will only have to
read these lines as ones of passing
interest.
On the other hand,
they may well be my last message to you
if they are no through all your life
that I loved you and baby with all my
heart and soul and that you to sweet
things were just all the world to me.
I pray,
God,
I may do my duty for I know that
whatever that may entail,
you would not have it otherwise and to
quote and Peter Hard with remarkable
sensitivity as a postscript and says,
quote Charles may the loving husband to
Bessie Mae and father to his baby,
pauline would indeed be killed.
The next day he is buried in the
dancing,
galley,
British cemetery,
small scale tragedies,
litter,
the history of war,
sad reminders that the necessities of
war ruined the lives of millions and the
quote it says,
we said all this pain from this war or
like pebbles dropped in water and the
ripples outward effect.
The rest of these societies,
when you have millions of people
impacted like this,
the ripple effect effects tens or maybe
even hundreds of millions of people
for a while.
The song becomes one of these pebbles
that's like ground zero for a huge
ripple effect that will affect Britain.
To this day.
I try to think about what mental state I
would be in after writing a letter like
that and when you think about millions
of people,
young people mostly being in situations
where they're writing a letter like
that,
how does that change?
You mean there are going to be
noticeable changes in this generation of
people in the four years during this
first World War I've been comparing this
period to a historical estuary,
right?
Where one generation and another
generation sort of mingled the the old
world and the new world,
but maybe it's more of a worm hole
through time and when this 19th century
group of people,
you know,
transitions through to the 20th century,
it's not going to make it intact.
It's going to suffer damage on the way
through.
It's like a birthing process to the
modern era and that can be bloody and
painful and potentially fatal to
the British have thought throughout this
war that they've taken large casualties
in the battles of 1915 places like
deliberately.
Those are large casualties for the
British,
which are a traditionally naval power
and employee relatively by continental
standards,
small armies.
This was the first time they've had a
large enough army to suffer the kind of
casualties that some nations like the
French or the Germans or the Russians
had been suffering this whole time.
On July first 1916,
the shelling subsides.
The whistles blow and these troops in
the morning or told to get out of their
trenches and had across into no man's
land and continued to take the German
defenses and this is where they find out
that the assumptions made in the
planning stages of this conflict haven't
come to pass the way the military
experts assumed they would.
And because of that,
British forces on the very first day of
the battle of the somme will suffer.
60,000
casualties,
20,000
dead.
There's never been a day like it in
British history and now all of a sudden
they can understand how the French felt
you on that August Day in 1914 when they
suffer 22,000
dead in an afternoon.
These are thoroughly modern casualties
into people not accustomed to them.
They are stunning and the fingers start
pointing immediately.
What the heck happened?
A generation of people who've felt this
visceral really have kept this debate
going and it continues between
historians even today.
What the hell happened?
Who's responsible for this?
What happened to the troops?
Will they got out of the trenches only
to find that in most areas,
the that this
artillery would smash up the wire wasn't
true and the wire was there.
It was a physical impediment in no man's
land trapping troops in the open so they
could be raped by machine gun fire,
artillery fire too,
but mainly machine gunfire from those
Germans who were not as badly affected
by the artillery either as the planners
had assumed they would be.
Tens of thousands of British soldiers
are being mowed down all the time.
One German on the other side of this
human tragedy at the battle of the Somme
on the first day is quoted in Ian
passing in his book,
all the Kaiser's men and he says,
quote,
the leading wave of British troops was
now halfway across.
No Man's land.
Get ready was passed along our front and
heads appeared over each shell crater
edge,
just final positions were taken up for
the best view and machine guns mounted
firmly in place.
A moment later when the first British
line was within 100 yards,
the rattle of machine gun and rifle fire
broke out along our whole line of shell
holes,
followed soon after by deadly accurate
shellfire,
the advanced rapidly crumbled under this
hail of Shell and bullets.
All along the line,
men could be seen throwing up their arms
and collapsing,
never to move again.
The extended lines,
though badly shaken and with many gaps
now came on all the faster.
Instead of a leisurely walk,
they covered the ground in short,
rushes at the double,
and within a few minutes the leading
troops had advanced to within a stone's
throw of our front trench again and
again.
The extended lines of British infantry
broke against the German defense like
waves against a cliff only to be beaten
back.
It was an amazing spectacle of
unexampled,
gallantry courage and bulldog
determination on both sides and quote.
Now those are the troops who made it
through the wire.
There were places where gaps had been
blown in the wire.
The problem was as the troops would
congregate at those gaps because they're
the only way to the other side,
and then get stuck in giant backups as
as a small stream of troops made it
through the corridor and those those
backups in those globs of soldiers just
waiting for their chance to get through
the corridor,
the wire would be mowed down by shell
fire and machine gun fire this day has
so affected the British,
in fact,
it's their version of redundancy.
What ridden is to the French soul.
The Psalm is to the British one,
and in his divided historians ever
since,
and you can see normally calm and sedate
rather cold.
Sometimes British historians lose their
head over this subject.
I mean John Keegan,
who,
um,
I've,
I've said it's not my favorite but,
but the,
the two world wars I think are,
are his strong point and you can tell
he's a guy who's hung out with some of
the enlisted troops that were trapped
that day at the somme because their
continued anger and incredibility about
this whole thing has rubbed off on him.
And by the way,
if you were trapped there like a sitting
duck on,
you know,
an open plane in no man's land watching
your buddies get blown to bits and
you're freaking out.
You would be thinking to,
who the hell put me here?
Who's responsible for this?
If I ever get out of this,
heads will roll.
And of course,
most of these British troops at this
battle or not have a class in British
society that could have made much of a
fuss,
but they've got loyal defenders who
will,
when this is over,
Keegan's one of them,
by the way,
you can.
You can just feel the anger when he
writes quote
in all,
the British had lost about 60,000
of whom 21,000
have been killed most in the first hour
of the attack.
Perhaps the first minutes the trenches
wrote Robert Key.
Fifty years later.
Now he's quoting Robert key quote where
the concentration camps of the first
world war now Keagan talks again and
though the analogy is what an academic
review or would call an historical,
there is something Treblinka like about
almost all accounts of the first of July
about these long dos lines of young men.
Shoddily uniformed heavily burdened
numbered about their next to identify
after they were killed,
plodding forward across a featureless
landscape to their own extermination.
Inside the barbed wire accounts of the
psalm,
he writes,
producing readers and audiences much the
same range of emotions as do
descriptions of the running of
Auschwitz,
guilty fascination,
incredulity,
horror,
disgust,
pity and anger and quote,
and then he goes on to say that this is
not just from the peaceniks and
tenderhearted out there,
not just from the military historians
where you get it from either but he
goes,
but from the professional troops to he
says,
quote,
anger is the response which the story of
the Somme most commonly evokes among
professionals,
meaning soldiers.
Why did the commander's not do something
about it?
Why do they let the attack go on?
Why did they not stop one battalion
following the wake of another to join it
in death and quote?
He then goes on to say that some
battalions were stopped,
but that's one of the things that so
many people got angry about is that once
you saw,
for example,
that the wire was still there,
why did you let more lines of troops get
up out of the trenches and followed the
people who just got destroyed in front
of them?
This is how someone like,
Hey,
Haig gets a reputation for a butcher.
Now I've gone out of my way in this
program.
I think you've probably noticed too in
1915,
cut these general slack because they're
learning,
right?
This is all new stuff and until you
experiment a little,
you don't know how to use it.
You don't know what it can do,
but at what point can you start holding
these people accountable for not
learning?
There was a great line from the civilian
political leader,
Germany,
a guy named Beth [inaudible] and he was
telling Kaiser by the end of 1916,
he's talking about Falcon nine here,
the German military leader,
but it could equally apply to a lot of
military leaders in this war,
especially at this time.
He asked the kaiser quote,
where does incompetency end and
criminality begin and to quote,
how many lives are you allowed to lose
experimenting before you learn your
lessons?
But there are a great many military
historians today who are trying once
again to say,
listen,
that's what they're doing.
We're still holding them to too high a
standard.
Too much hindsight going on here.
Here's what Peter Harte writes,
quote,
for many people,
the Psalm and the equally ugly Verdun
have come to symbolize the great war.
Few child battles fought with other
people's lives by incompetence and
uncaring generals in particular for the
British.
He says,
the disaster of the first of July on the
Psalm has become the sole prism through
which the conduct of the whole of the
great war has been viewed.
There is no light and shade here,
just a dark,
just spare the numbing horror of the
teaming casualties,
explanations of what went wrong and why
are thrust aside indeed in the past,
subdued references to a quote end quote,
learning curve for the generals have
been seen as an insult to the dead.
There remains a widespread belief.
He writes that there must have been a
better way something else could or
should have been done.
Someone must be blamed.
Much of this appropriate has fallen on
the head of Douglas Haig,
who has at times been reviled as a mass
murderer.
Yet this was the inevitable price of
engaging in continental warfare on the
main field of battle against the primary
enemy.
France was well accustomed to the pain
of continental warfare,
but for Britain it was a new experience.
Germany had no exposed flanks,
just the imposing fortifications of the
western front defending their 1914 gains
rested from France and Belgium.
Unfortunately for all their tactical
improvement and technical innovations
that British were just simply not able
to breach those defenses or kill
sufficient Germans even in concert with
the French at Verdun to bring Germany to
its knees and to quote.
It also makes you wonder a little about
the quality of the human beings who are
commanding these endeavors were making
these plans and who are watching all
these people die and be wounded because
of these plans.
In other words,
how bad does the general field the next
day?
Well,
it's not something you can easily figure
out.
Again,
John Keegan seems to be so angry at the
field marshal here.
I'm still for this conflict that he,
he,
he writes an answer to that question,
kind of what kind of man do you have to
be to suffer those kinds of casualties?
And the next day think about continuing.
Keegan writes,
quote,
Hey,
meg,
whom his contemporaries found difficult
to know has become today and enigma,
the successful generals of the first
world war,
those who did not crack outright or
decline gradually into pessimism.
We're a hard lot as they had to be with
the casualty figures accumulating on
their desk.
Some nonetheless managed to combine
toughness of mind with some striking
human characteristic is y'all.
He says imperturbability,
Hindenburg,
gravity,
fall,
fire,
Kemal certainty.
Hey,
he says in whose public manner and
private diaries,
no concern for human suffering was or is
discernible,
compensated for his aloofness with
nothing whatsoever of the common touch.
He seemed to move through the horrors of
the first world war as if guided by some
inner voice.
Speaking of a higher purpose and a
personal destiny that we now know he
says was not just appearance.
Haig was a devoted both of spiritualist
practices and a fundamentalist religion.
As a young officer,
he had taken to attending seances where
the medium put him in touch with
Napoleon as commander in chief.
He fell under the influence of a
Presbyterian chaplain who's sermons
confirmed him in his belief that he was
in direct communication with God and had
a major part to play in a divine plan
for the world.
His own simple religion Keagan says he
was convinced was shared by his soldiers
who were inspired thereby to bear the
dangers and sufferings which were there
part of the war.
He was directing and quote,
wow,
welcome to the controversy and the heat
that the battle of the Somme has
generated amongst those who write about
it,
but justifiably so,
I think I'm truthfully,
I think there were military people who
were certainly willing to forgive
Douglas Haig for suffering.
60,000
casualties on the first day of the
battle of the somme.
If he didn't flick,
did something like 60,000
on the Germans.
Instead the British suffer.
Those kinds of casualty in the German
casualties may have been as low as
6,000.
12,000
is the high number of you sometimes see
split the difference,
say 8,000,
so take 60,
give eight.
You get your face ripped off.
Not exactly the position you want,
your brand new general,
the new blood.
The person is going to bring a new sense
of success to the war on the western
front.
All of a sudden,
Douglas Haig doesn't look a whole lot
better than the people who came before
him.
Heck,
John French could have had your separate
60,000
casualties on the first day of the
Somme,
right?
The previous commander.
Now to put those numbers in perspective,
because I always have to do this for
myself.
60,000.
That's an amorphous number.
What?
What does that compare to?
You have to understand that the British
for 101 years by the battle of the
psalms time had been talking about a
horrible day.
They'd suffered,
you know,
finishing off Napoleon,
the waterloo,
right in 18,
15 on Napoleon killed 84 British
soldiers.
Eighty 400 compared to 20 or 21 or
19,000.
That's huge difference,
right?
But how about the Second World War?
You always think of the second world war
as being worse than the first when the
British and Americans landed on the
beaches of Normandy on June six,
19,
44 for the famous Dj landings,
and then pushed inland a not enough
attention paid to key part of that whole
thing.
You know,
widening at the bridge had,
it was hard combat.
It was historically hard combat,
but it took the British and the
Americans combined 20 days to reach
20,000
casualties,
so it took them 20 days combined British
and Americans to reach one third.
The amount of casualties,
the British alone suffered on the first
day of the battle of the somme.
That's wild.
That's crazy.
And it sounds like Verdun doesn't it?
Those numbers start to sound like what
the French are suffering,
that horrible battle to bleed their army
white.
Well,
David Fromkin in his book,
a piece to end all peace quotes Norman
stone about,
you know,
how large these battles were compared to
what the people in Europe are used to.
And he says,
quote,
it has been estimated that the total of
military and civilian casualties in all
of Europe,
domestic and international conflicts in
the hundred years between 18,
15 and 1915 was no greater than a single
day's combat losses in any of the great
battles of 1916 and quote,
that's an incredible statistic when you
think of all of the battles that
Europeans fought in Europe and in
colonies and all those things,
all of it put together and all of the
European countries for a hundred years
doesn't equal one of the bad days at
Verdun or the somme.
The societies that could handle these
kinds of casualties were remarkable,
but they took their toll.
As you might imagine by the time five
months of the psalm is over,
you have another million casualties
basically in five months.
So freedom gives you roughly about a
million.
And the Psalm gives you roughly about a
million all at the same time.
The burn rate on the western front is
horrifying in 1916.
And remember,
all of these battles are like a lot of
littler battles sort of lumped together
at the somme.
For example,
the Germans will counter attack in that
five month period,
more than 300 times a ton of those
counterattacks in ancient times would
have been a battle all by itself,
right?
Part of the reason why it's so hard to
follow the nature of these battles.
Churchill has an overall description
that is just horrifying of a conceptual
view of this that makes you understand
what really going on,
if you could view it sort of from space,
and he writes about both the Somme and
verdun quote,
the anatomy of the battles of Verdun and
the Somme was the same.
A battlefield had been selected around
this battlefield.
Walls were built double,
triple,
quadruple,
have enormous cannon.
Behind these railways were constructed
to feed them and mountains are shells
were built up.
All this was the work of months.
Thus,
the battlefield was completely encircled
by thousands of guns of all sizes and a
wide oval space prepared in their midst.
Through this awful arena,
all the divisions of each army battered
ceaselessly by the enveloping artillery
were made to pass in succession as if
they were in the teeth of interlocking
cog wheels grinding each other for month
after month,
he writes,
the ceaseless cannonade continued at its
utmost intensity and month after month,
the gallon divisions of heroic human
beings were torn to pieces in this
terrible rotation.
Then came the winter,
pouring down rain from the sky to clog
the feet of men and drawing veils of
missed before the Hawk eyes of their
artillery.
The arena as used to happen in the
coliseum in those miniature Roman days
was flooded with water.
A vast sea of in sanguine mage earned by
thousands of vehicles by hundreds of
thousands of men and millions of shells
replaced the blasted dust.
Still,
the struggle continued still,
the remorseless wheels revolved still.
The auditorium of artillery roared at
last.
The legs of men could no longer move.
They wallowed in,
floundered helplessly in the slime.
They are food and ammunition lagged
behind them along the smash in choked
roadways.
And to quote,
I keep quoting Churchill because wasn't
that positively tolken ask by the way,
there are people who you know,
say that Tolkien's experiences with the
first world war influenced in his way of
writing and thinking,
but if it did,
he would have been just one of millions
of other people that had their outlook
transformed by this conflict.
And how could you not?
As we said,
you imagine writing that last letter
home where it's essentially a goodbye
letter that can change you,
can't it?
I known a lot of people who've had
terminal illnesses,
had months to know that death was in
their near future.
It often changes them.
It often creates this introspective
mood.
We're all of a sudden they're focusing
on subjects that people don't usually
spend hour after hour,
day after day,
focusing on,
but it's right in front of them,
right?
If you have terminal cancer,
it's going to be on your mind and the
thinking about it changes you.
What if you had a terminal disease and
all of a sudden at the last minute the
doctors figured out a way to cure you
when you were dragged back from the
brink,
but you'd spend a couple of months
thinking intensely about life and death
and the meaning of things and what you
would've done differently in all these
really heavy duty thoughts that most
people can only stand to think about in
short little bursts.
Usually there are exceptions.
Now,
imagine millions of people during this
19,
14,
18 period who would have found
themselves in a similar sort of a
situation.
Pretty much sure they were going to die
in the near future.
We'll be horribly disfigured thinking
about the heaviest of subjects,
writing letters home to loved ones
saying,
you know,
I'm going to miss not knowing my baby
daughter,
and then some of them getting a reprieve
and getting a chance to live this life.
They were all but writing off during the
worst of these war experiences.
That is a searing personal experience
that millions of individual persons went
through.
How does that not change the society
when they go home and you know,
one of the things about battles,
especially these first world war battles
is they're so dark,
aren't they and theirs so industrial and
they're so unbelievably horrifying.
The charnal houses,
Zombie graveyard feel of the
battlefields and the first world war
make that particularly in a mind
bending.
You'll see a lot of art around the first
world war that shows corpses decaying
and it's not so you feel sympathy with
the dead figure.
It's so that you understand what it was
like for those people living amongst all
those decaying corpse is to deal with
that reality.
Mind bending battles mind bending
enough,
right?
You add all the incredible artillery,
which is disorienting as as all get out
and then throw in bodies,
pieces of bodies everywhere when you're
living,
as we've said,
it's a unique experience.
It's a form of hell and yet to someone
like yours truly that creates the
circumstances where human brotherly love
appears so like a light in the darkness.
Part of why battles are interesting to
study is because as you probably figured
out,
you can see the worst of human behavior
and man's inhumanity to man in them,
but you can also see these pieces of
humanity slip through and when they do,
they are all the more bright and
noticeable because they're happening in
hell as opposed to,
you know,
something that happens in your
neighborhood,
right little piece of humanity,
not that surprising in your neighborhood
probably makes your day a little
brighter.
A piece of humanity in the hell have
these battlefields has a rejuvenating
effect for ones feel about man.
Take for example the sacrifice.
These no man's land in the fighting
lines of the two sides on the western
front created something that the battles
have had forever.
I mean in the Second World War,
you'd have these crossroads,
for example,
where some machine gunner had set up and
now all of a sudden,
you know,
it was death to cross this crossroads,
but the western front is hundreds of
miles of trench lines.
All of them with this dead zone in
between and on the really big fronts
where a lot was happening,
there was tons of drama in those dead
zones.
Things would happen that would challenge
men's morality and what you're willing
to do.
A perfect example is in the battle of
the somme.
When the 60,000
casualties and a lot of other casualties
over the course of that battle are
happening,
the Germans are often taking pity on
their fellow human beings and the
British right about it.
I mean when these British attacks would
break against the German defenses and
the wounded would start back toward the
safety of their own trenches,
grabbing even worse wounded people with
them and trying to under machine guns
and artillery fire get back to their own
trenches.
A lot of times these Germans would just
stop shooting on the first terrible day.
There were oftentimes where the machine
gunners in the officers would just say,
stop,
let them get back.
It's the human thing to do.
Right?
On the other hand,
if they had just machine gun them,
that window surprised anybody either,
but what do you do now about those
people who are stuck out there in no
man's land after the attack is over?
There are all sorts of stories about
people who will simply,
if they can drag themselves to the
nearest shell hole,
wrap themselves up in the tarp.
They keep to keep the rain out,
you know,
open up a Bible and just die in those
shell holes,
but when they don't,
they can often have a terrible effect on
the men in the trenches,
on both sides.
The Apaches in the American south west
used to be able to make such good use of
hostages and if you threatened to
torture a hostage or you did torture a
hostage,
you could get all kinds of concessions
from the other side.
Well,
there are hostages that fate is holding
in the middle of those no man's land
areas.
And what do you do when one of them
starts asking for help and they're
basically calling to you and your body's
from no man's land.
If you want to see their heroism and the
sacrifice that human beings can show in
in these hellish situations,
read the accounts over and over about
how men dealt with screams for help from
no man's land.
A perfect example of the kind of moral
dilemmas and self sacrifice that these
situations,
you know create is the story that Robert
Graves tells in goodbye all that when he
was serving at the Somme on the western
front and a soldier named Samson gets
hit in the wave before graves is wave
goes over the top.
So graves is just getting ready for this
intense experience himself of going over
the top of the trench with other human
beings right into the teeth of machine
gunfire.
And all of a sudden you hear the sound
of somebody from the last attack,
from no man's land.
You know where it's death to stand up
and move around asking for help or
screaming out.
And here's what graves rights.
Remember,
he's,
he's in the state himself and thinking,
okay,
I've got to walk into machine gunfire
and I've just seen all these other
people die in front of me.
Quote,
my mouth was dry,
my eyes out of focus and my legs quaking
under me.
I found a water bottle full of Ramen,
drank about half a pint.
It quieted me in.
My head remained clear.
Samson lay groaning about 20 yards
beyond the front trench.
Several attempts were made to rescue
him.
He'd been very badly hit.
Three men got killed in those attempts
to officers in two men wounded in the
end,
his own orderly managed to crawl out to
him.
Samson waved him back saying he was
riddled through and not worth rescuing.
He sent his apologies to the company for
making such noise and the quote.
In other words,
this guy is out there screaming and it's
so driving his own comrades crazy that
they keep running out there to do
something and everyone who runs out
there to do something gets killed.
At what point,
if you're the wounded person,
do you try to just stop making noise so
that they don't keep trying to help you
out of sympathy when you probably are
dying anyway and now you've lost three
people or more simply trying to prevent
the inevitable you're going through.
So at night when we're told the no man's
land area comes to life and you know,
we're appears deserted during the
daytime.
At night,
the trench patrols go out.
The people who you know fix the barbed
wire,
the intelligence folks,
the people conducting trench raids.
I mean supposedly there's a lot of
activity in the dark.
Even though star shells light up the sky
all the time at dark graves in his unit
moves out to go cleared any wounded in
front of their trenches.
And he writes,
quote at dusk.
We all went out to get the wounded
leaving only centuries in the line.
The first dead body I came upon was
Samson's hit in 17 places.
I found that he had forced his knuckles
into his mouth to stop himself crying
out and attracting any more men to their
death.
And to quote,
so this poor man out there hit 17 times
suffering,
horribly unable to keep from crying out,
can't stand the thought of attracting
anymore and men to rescue him and dies
with his hand in his mouth to keep from
crying.
I mean it,
it,
it's,
it's the beauty that,
that,
that finds its way into the horrific
ness of this war.
If you're that person's parent,
there's nothing to consoles you that
doesn't make you feel any better,
but as a human being,
you look at that and say,
there's something about that man's
sacrifice that's beautiful.
Now graves tells another story,
which not only shows the heroism and the
beauty of one of his compatriots,
but the same sort of an attitude on the
part of the people.
The British thought were the bad guys.
The Germans,
as we said,
the Germans had been holding their fire
quite a bit.
You know,
during this battle and you see it on the
French side.
And the British side too.
I mean this is not abnormal.
It's a little bit like that Christmas
truce we talked about in the 1914,
a era of this war were spontaneously
troops got up and sort of gave each
other a little Christmas love in between
the shellings,
right.
You see this humanity appear even in
this hell.
Graves talks about another soldier in no
man's land who wakes up in a seemingly
dead and then all of a sudden is crying
for help,
and when this happens,
every man in his trench feels like he's
going through some sort of a moral
tasked and one man passes it with flying
colors.
Graves writes quote,
on the morning of the 27th,
a cry arose from no man's land.
A wounded soldier of the middle sex unit
had recovered consciousness.
After two days,
he lay close to the German wire.
Our men heard it and looked at each
other.
We had a tender hearted lance corporal
named Baxter.
He was the man to boil up a special
dixie for the centuries of his section.
When they came off duty,
made them a little soup or tea.
As soon as he heard the wounded
Middlesex man,
he ran along the trench calling for a
volunteer to help fetch him in.
Of course,
no one would go.
It was death to put one's head over the
parapet.
When he came running to ask me,
I excused myself as being the only
officer in the company.
I would come out with him at dusk.
I said,
not now.
So he went alone.
He jumped quickly over the parapet and
then strolled across no man's land,
waving a handkerchief.
The Germans fire to frighten him,
but since he persisted,
they let him come.
Close.
Baxter continued toward them and when he
got to the Middlesex man stopped and
pointed to show the Germans what he was
at,
meaning what he was up to.
Then he dressed the man's wounds,
gave him a drink of rom and some
biscuits that he had with him and
promised to be back again at nightfall.
He did come back.
Graves writes with a stretcher party and
the man eventually recovered.
I recommended Baxter for the Victoria
Cross being the only officer who had
witnessed the action,
but the authorities thought it worth no
more than a distinguished conduct medal
and the quote
sounds worthy of a Victoria cross to me,
and that's one of those incidents where
you see the opposite of man's
inhumanity.
Demand in an environment designed to
foster the former.
It stands out all the more,
doesn't it?
That baxter could have easily been mowed
down and if you don't think it happens.
Remember three people were mowed down
trying to say that wounded Samson
character in the first graves story,
I can't help but wonder how my
generation would handle what these
people forced to do.
You think of the first day on the battle
of the somme.
Think of yourself in the second wave or
the third wave and you hear all this
stuff from the officers about all the
artillery will destroy everybody that
nobody will be left alive,
and then the first wave in front of you
units that you know go over the top and
don't even get near their objective
before they're cut to ribbons.
It's an absolute catastrophe and screw
up and everybody can see it happening
and then they turn into the next wave.
Maybe that's not you.
Maybe you're in the third and tell them
to go do the same thing and they do in
the same thing happens,
right?
It's suicide.
Now they turn to you and they say,
okay,
it's your unit turn.
What do you do?
Forget cowardice for a second because
there are people who simply ran away or
who's nerves failed them or whatever.
This is not a question of,
you know,
what could you do physically?
This is a question of what would you do?
See,
I think a lot of us would think to
ourselves,
there's no way I'm surviving going out
onto that battlefield,
but if this officer wasn't here telling
me to do this and my buddies and I just
sort of decided all together,
we're not doing this.
Maybe something would change.
You know,
one of the first war novels to come out
of the first world war actually came out
during the first world war from a
Frenchman named Henri barbless,
and he wrote something where he as a
soldier had served already.
He was a disabled veteran.
He wrote this piece while the war was
still going on and it's surprisingly
antiwar for the government to have put
up with it during the conflict and he
implied that the soldiers on both sides,
the common soldiers should just agree
with each other that they're not going
to fight anymore.
You know what?
If they gave a war and no one came,
right?
What if the soldiers on both sides say,
well,
the government's can tell us to fight,
but we're not fighting anymore.
And Barbara said that in the book that
the truthfully the only people who
really understood what the French
soldier and the British soldier we're
going through in these hellish
conditions where the German soldiers on
the other side of the no man's land
living under the exact same hellish
conditions.
When the Germans don't fire on the
British who are getting their wounded
and a lot of times just because there's
this unwritten deal that says,
I'm gonna,
leave you alone right now to get your
wounded people out of there in the hopes
that when it's my wounded people in no
man's land and I'm trying to get them
out of there,
you'll let me.
One of the real phenomenons of this war
is the fact that when left alone,
a lot of soldiers on both sides decided
to adopt what's what's officially known
as a live and let live attitude in this
war and it was.
It was common everywhere,
but the western front more than any
other where for example,
soldiers would be required and they
hated this job to go out at night and
put more barbed wire up in the middle of
no man's land.
So you sneak out because it's dark and
you bring wire with and wire cutters and
all these things and you have to go hang
new wire.
It's an extremely dangerous job in both
sides.
Hated it.
Right?
So a lot of times they just wouldn't
shoot.
At the other people who were putting
wire up,
now the officers hated this and one of
the big scandals was after the Christmas
truce,
the so called Christmas truce in 1914
when both sides would have fraternized.
The officers had to make all these
arrangements so that next Christmas,
nothing like this happened again,
and the men had preserved a proper
fighting spirit would be the way most of
these militaries would phrase it,
but the troops often found a lot more to
like about each other than their own
officers.
Corporal Louis Bartos in the French army
writes about this incident where a flood
occurs and all of a sudden the trenches
on both sides of no man's land have to
clear and how you have one of those
moments where you just look at your
enemy and he looks at you and you
realize the socks and who put us into
this mess and why are we doing this?
And he almost writes,
you know,
Martez is a socialist.
Like a lot of these troops in the
trenches are.
So he has a worldview that kind of sees
the upper classes,
the corporate groups and all that is the
problem and that the average soldiers in
the trenches,
we're all just kind of common workers
being exploited by the man and he writes
about this famous a flood that he
experiences and what it does and how it
freaks out,
you know,
in his mind,
the upper classes in the officer corps
that all of a sudden,
you know,
both sides in this combat are starting
to have some sympathy for each other.
And he writes quote.
But one night when the rain came down in
torrance,
the tide invaded our dugout and cascaded
down both sets of steps at the height of
the storm.
Some of the men had to devote all their
efforts to building a dam,
which the water then broke through in
three or four places.
We spent the rest of the night battling
the floodwaters.
The next day,
December 10th,
at many places along the front line,
the soldiers had to come out of their
trenches.
So as not to drown.
The Germans had to do the same.
We therefore had the singular spectacle
of the two enemy armies facing each
other without firing a shot.
Our common sufferings brought our hearts
together,
melted the hatreds,
nurtured sympathy between strangers and
adversaries.
Those who deny it are ignoring human
psychology,
French,
German,
and Germans.
He writes,
looked at each other and saw that they
were all men.
No different from one another.
They smiled,
exchanged comments,
hands reached out and grasped.
We shared tobacco,
a canteen of coffee or wine if only we
spoke the same language.
One day he writes a huge devil of a
German,
stood up on a mound and gave a speech,
which only the Germans could understand
word for word,
but everyone knew what it meant because
he smashed his rifle on a tree stump,
breaking it into in a gesture of anger.
Applause broke out on both sides and the
international was sung.
He says the national anthem of the
socialist cause I guess you could say
the workers,
cause he says,
quote,
well,
if only you'd been there.
Mad King's bloody generals,
fanatical ministers,
jingoistic journalists,
Rear Echelon Patriots to contemplate
this sublime spectacle.
But it wasn't enough.
He says that the soldiers refused to
fight one another.
What was needed was for them to turn
back on the monsters who were pushing
them,
one against the other,
and to cut them down like wild beasts
for not having done so.
How much longer would the killing go on?
Meanwhile,
he says,
our big shot leaders were in a fearer.
What in the Lord's name would happen if
the soldiers refused to kill each other?
Our artillery men received orders to
fire on any assemblies of men which were
pointed out to them and to mow down
indiscriminately,
both French,
German,
and Germans.
Just like when an ancient circuses,
they slaughtered wild beast too.
We're too intelligent to tear each
other's throats out and devour each
other.
Furthermore,
he says once the front line was
established,
again,
for better or worse,
it was forbidden under penalty of death
to leave the trench.
Any active familiarity with the Germans
had to cease.
It was over.
What was really needed was a second
biblical flood,
a universal deleuze to stop the war,
to appease all the anger and the bloody
madness of our leaders.
Who knows?
He says,
maybe one day in this corner of law,
they will raise a monument to
commemorate this spirit of fraternity
among men who shared a horror of war and
who were forced to kill each other
against their wills and quote,
there are multiple accounts from
socialists,
soldiers that sound like that,
but it's more complex than that,
and Philip Gibbs tries to make this
statement and now it can be told where
he talks about this horrible life.
These poor soldiers are forced to
endure,
but then about the complexity involved
in trying to make some statement that
the soldiers are all of one mind or
viewpoint about anything
we told you.
Ernst,
Young,
or the German goes through all this
terrible stuff and kind of finds it
uplifting.
Gibbs writes these horror stories and
then says this about the psalm and the
soldiers,
their quote,
but however deep the knowledge of
tragedy,
a man would be a liar if he refused to
admit the heroism,
the gallantry of youth,
even the gaiety of men in these infernal
months.
Psychology on the somme was not simple
and straightforward.
Men were afraid,
but fear was not there dominating
emotion except in the worst hours.
Men hated this fighting,
but found excitement in it,
often exultation,
sometimes an intense stimulus of all
their senses and passions before
reaction and exhaustion.
Men became gibbering idiots with shell
shock as I saw some of them,
but others rejoiced when they saw our
shells plowing into the enemy's
earthworks,
laughed at their own narrow escapes and
at grotesque comma,
calories of this monster is devil tree.
The officers he writes were proud of
their men,
eager for their honor and achievement.
The men themselves were in rivalries
with other bodies of troops and proud of
their own prowess.
They were scoring full of all that the
enemy might do to them.
You get acknowledged his courage and
power.
They were quick to kill him and yet also
quick to give him a chance of life by
surrender and after that we're nine
times out of 10,
chivalrous and kindly,
but incredibly brutal.
On the rare occasions when passion
overcame them at some tail of treachery,
they had the pride of a skilled laborer.
He writes in his own craft as machine
gunners bombers,
raider trench,
motor men,
and we're all keen to show their skill,
whatever the risks,
they were healthy animals with animal
courage as well as animal fear,
and they had some of them,
a spiritual and moral fervor which made
them risk.
Death to save a comrade or to save a
position would have killed the fear that
tried to fetter them or lead men with
greater fear than theirs.
They live from hour to hour and forgot
the parallel or the misery that had
passed and did not forestall the future
by apprehension,
unless they were a sensitive mind with
the worst quality men might have in
modern warfare,
imagination and to quote well,
imagination.
I can see being a downside if you are in
the trenches under fire,
you know,
looking at your watch as some of these
troops in the trenches did.
Saying I have 15 minutes left to live.
Now I have 10 minutes left to live.
Now I have five minutes left to live as
the countdown to going over the top
happened.
Yes,
I can see how that would drive you
crazy.
On the other hand,
we're getting to the part of the war
were the really imaginative minds can
begin to start to have an impact on
these brand new 20th century problems.
It only became apparent about two years
ago when this war started.
Some of the solutions to the problems.
The first world war you know,
brings into play debut during the battle
of the Somme and they look once again,
this is going to make me be a sub theme
of the show unintentionally.
They looked like something out of
science fiction in this case,
hg wells or if you want to believe some
people go all the way back to Leonardo
Davinci.
People who first come up with the
concept of if you will,
a land ship,
Churchill and the navy called them land
battle ships.
Sometimes we know them by the term tank
on tank is supposedly simply something
that caught on.
It was supposed to be a cover word so
that no one knew what was being worked
on in secret in the laboratories of the
allies.
They would suggest that this giant
armored tractor was intended to bring up
supply.
You know,
like water to the front line,
troops under fire,
so a tank if you will,
a water tank on a battle,
one of these little battles that make up
all these giant battles,
a part of the battle of the Somme on
September 15th and offensive to take a
particular part of the battlefield is
launched and debuting are a bunch of
these tanks,
you know,
30 or 40,
something like that.
A bunch of them broke down on the way.
You can instantly see that this is the
solution to the problem,
right?
If you go to your engineers when the war
starts and say,
listen,
we've got this barbed wire machine gun
artillery situation with no man's land
and these big trenches,
you got to get past a.
put your mind to it.
Come back with a design they did.
They've got a giant tractor and it's so
long that it can span most of these
trenches so it can go in and not get
trapped.
Most of the time it only goes about the
speed of a walking human being,
but the point isn't to,
you know,
drive around real fast everywhere.
The point is to not get killed while
you're crossing no man's land and not
get held up by barbed wire.
These things are designed to simply run
over barbed wire machine.
Gun Bullets won't hurt them,
shrapnel won't hurt them and they'll get
to the other side and they'll wipe out
strong points and when they debut,
nobody has any idea what that's going to
be like.
It's another one of those moments where
you kind of bite your nails and you
watched the new technology in this case,
not stuff developed in the last hundred
years that never had a chance to be
tested.
In this case,
stuff developed specifically in response
to problems.
The first world war you know,
brings up like no man's land and they
perform astoundingly well.
Now they break down a lot and they're
terribly uncomfortable for the people
inside.
These are large too.
There's like 15 people in these things.
I mean they're like almost a boss and
they don't have a turret.
They have either a machine gunner coming
under the side or a couple of six
pounder guns,
which are about 57 millimeter,
and yet the Germans don't know what
they're dealing with here,
and we'd have stories of them
surrendering the tanks and,
uh,
the reaction on the part of the British
troops is either really excited and
happy or they almost laughing because it
looks kind of comical,
but in a sense,
this is what we talked about earlier.
This is the star wars team punk imperial
Walker thing for real
now,
Churchill and the people who had backed
this idea from the time trench warfare
got started.
That's when the first plans were drawn
up in the ideas brainstormed for
something like this in the French were
working on a two by the way.
Churchill was mad and forever afterwards
yelled and screamed that this concept
could have really done a ton if they had
just waited till there were enough of
these land battleships,
um,
to unleash and have,
have it make a difference.
The counterargument,
which we also understand,
right?
Is that what if they don't work?
What if we don't know how they work,
how do we do this if we don't have a
dress rehearsal before opening night,
so churchill and the people on his side
are saying,
no,
you wasted it.
It should've been one big opening night
that broke the western front and the
other side saying,
are you kidding me?
There is an open invitation and Murphy's
law,
but if you were looking to try to decide
how you liked your land battleship
concept in practice after it was debuted
at the battle of the somme,
well,
all you have to know,
his cavalry commander Douglas Haig,
radioed back to corporate headquarters
into the British army and said,
we want more of those tanks now.
Other things happened because of the
battle of the somme.
Two and one was it was just it for poor
Eric von Falcon Hein,
the head of the German military.
Remember he's a guy who took over after
they sacked von Moltke,
the guy who they started the war with
and now like a bunch of leaders who own
a football team and continually like to
change coaches.
Falcon Heinz going to lose his gig.
He's got verdun on his scorecard,
now he's got the song and then there's
this bruce law of offensive and then the
last straw is everybody's whispering
that Romania is going to get in the war,
which doesn't sound like a big deal to
us now,
but if you actually look at the
literature,
especially German Austro-hungarian,
the stuff from that side of Europe,
oh,
they're really like biting their nails
about this.
Romania could get in the war.
Half million bayonets.
Oh my goodness.
And everybody's really worried.
And apparently Kaiser Wilhelm,
the German emperor is really worried in
fucking hindsight now.
Don't worry about it.
They're not going to come in anytime
soon.
Maybe later,
but no,
but no time soon.
And then boom,
almost right after he issues the,
they won't be coming in.
They come in August 27th.
Uh,
and that's it.
Fall behind.
Get sacked.
The last card,
by the way,
I love how he knows his emperor William
and William's little quirks about power
and Falcon Heinz last car that he plays
is,
you know,
if you replace me with the people
everyone knew they were going to replace
it with.
If you replaced me with Hindenburg and
Ludendorff,
that's it.
They're not gonna.
Listen to you.
I'm the last chance you have of having
an influence.
My words,
but that's basically what he said to the
Kaiser.
You wouldn't have any role in this at
all.
You better stick with me because if you
put Hindenburg and Ludendorff in charge,
they're going to tell you to go play
with your toys in the corner.
Apparently the kaiser felt like he had
no choice.
Sacks,
Fond Falcon Hein,
who asks for a military command is
given.
Some people think almost as an insult,
the command to go attack Romania,
which he didn't first see them coming
into the war.
He takes over a military command and
conducts a brilliant campaign against
Romania.
Conquering them quickly,
which makes you turn around and go,
now,
why were we so scared of those Romanian
bayonets?
It's not the Romanians fault,
by the way,
folks.
I mean,
think about how that's like a minor
league team jumping into the middle of a
game against the perhaps army in the
20th century.
So finally Romania.
So unequipped for this without a ramp up
period.
And they just got smashed and the worst
part about the whole thing from the
allied standpoint,
again,
the allies worked so hard to get Romania
in.
The conflict is that one's Germany takes
over Romania,
they're gonna lose that country of every
bit of wheat and oil and anything they
can take to offset the damage that the
British blockade is doing.
So in a sense it's like they come upon
this Romanian store room and they loot
the whole thing so it sort of backfires
on the allied cause.
Nonetheless,
Hindenburg and Ludendorff,
this new command team,
the people who had been in charge on the
eastern front for so long and sort of
being the armchair quarterbacks from
over there telling the rest of the
German command what they were doing
wrong on the western front are now in
charge of among other things the western
front and they're going to bring a new
perspective and a different way of
looking at things and they will
essentially command this German army for
the rest of the war.
Now,
how long the rest of the war is going to
be able to go is an open question.
As 1916 begins to wind up,
you begin to see the discontent ramping
up everywhere and on many different
fronts.
When you begin to see,
for example,
hunger really bite,
there'll be a winter,
the famous winter of 1916 in Germany.
That's called the turnip winter,
which tells you right there what's going
on and all the.
All the exports from Romania you can get
aren't going to,
you know,
make up for the overseas important needs
of Germany.
The Russians are in terrible trouble.
Remember,
this is a regime that almost got
overthrown 10 years before this time
period.
They didn't have exactly the greatest,
most solid foundation anyway.
These million casualties,
they suffer in 1916 at the Bristol off
offensive.
Among other things are taking its toll.
French soldiers are beginning to bleed
like sheep.
When they pass by their officers,
these replacements will come up marching
by and they'll just hear bleeding.
Sounds like sheep and lamb being led to
the slaughter as sort of as one author
puts it.
I'm way that the troops can silently
protest what they feel is being done to
them and on the home front you can,
you know the tragedy is beginning to
really seep in as more and more people
are personally affected for life by this
conflict,
and obviously while this isn't the
textbook example,
I don't think most people find
themselves in in the same situation as
this German couple,
but there's a story from the time period
from a British observer in Germany
during the war who was describing a
train trip where she saw a couple man
and a woman on the train and the stories
absolutely heartbreaking,
but in so many ways shows where we are.
By the end of 1916 in this conflict,
the observer says,
quote,
how poor woman the other day on the
train was holding up her hand and
counting the fingers on it.
Slowly,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
Over and over again,
the passengers gradually began to smile
at her until at last,
the man sitting next to her said,
simply don't laugh at my wife,
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm taking her to the asylum.
Her wits are gone.
She's lost her five sons all killed in
action and quote,
when you really examine what's already
happened since August 19,
14,
you come away with the feeling that if
you had bet on a short war like so many
did,
you are amazed at the staying power of
all these states,
many of whom didn't look that
particularly stable when the war broke
out.
Nonetheless,
as we've been saying throughout this
whole program,
there's a limit to the endurance of
anyone and we're about to enter the
point when nations crack and break and
in the not too distant future get
knocked out.
If you think the show you just heard is
worth a dollar,
Dan and Ben would love to have it.
A buck a show.
It's all we ask.
Go to Dan Carlin.com
for information on how to donate to the
show.
One of the justifiable criticisms you
can level at the show we just did was
that it focuses in ordinarily on the
western front.
I did that on purpose because to me,
when you're talking about the extremes
of human experience,
the first thing that comes to my mind
when I think of the first world war is
the situation on the western front and
the trench war and all that,
and in that sense I'm not that different
than most British,
French and German historians who have
focused inordinately on the western
front,
but I think we all know that there's a
lot of other things going on in this
conflict in a bunch of other theaters
and in the same way I was able to avoid
talking about those other theaters for
awhile.
My goodness,
the jumping around.
We would do if,
if we try to get everything in there
would be more confusing than what we're
already giving you,
which is more confusing than I like
already.
Nonetheless,
you could ignore her just like most
people in Britain,
France or heck,
even in New York City.
In the United States,
when you open up a newspaper and in the
far corner of like page eight,
there's a little blurb about maybe some
obscure Arab tribe uprising in some.
Out of the way,
autumn in district or something doesn't
mean that much to you.
You're not thinking that much about it.
After all,
the western front is grinding up a whole
generation of Europeans and then in 1917
events in faraway peripheral places is
the way a lot of people in the West
might see them rise up and demand to be
taken seriously,
whether it's the Middle East in 1917 and
events that we are still shaking out to
this day that are in your headlines
daily,
whether it's the collapse of an ancient
European regime which opens the door to
the 20th century's most radical regime
taking over in a major country.
So also in 1917 that the vortex of the
first world war manages to suck in an
outside major power.
That for almost a 150 years has managed
to stay out of direct involvement in
European affairs.
As one of their early presidents had
said,
the United States of America doesn't go
abroad in search of foreign monsters to
slay.
And in 1917 they decide we'll maybe just
this once,
you know,
to make the world safe for democracy.
Yes,
indeed.
Many of our modern situations had the
seeds for them planted in 1917.
And we'll get to all that and more in
part five of blueprint for Armageddon.